oh my god
Wow and took us a car removed the wrong
rope stingy pile he hopes his rippling G
the D to the G to a check
Bradley rookie III and g3 here than
winning steady quickly moved the long
rope yeah G son is he shaking his head
head looking around like oh my god Ben
wonder that game his eyes could you
fight he's like oh we're out that was a
mistake
[Music]
and
the games go on with me here Grand
Master Robert Hess for the second speed
chess championship match of the year
after a thrilling albeit maybe somewhat
surprising result on Tuesday with Levon
Aronian moving on in fashion against
Nagano Caruana today we have one of the
heavy favorites in the entire event of
course the overall number one seed
Hikaru Nakamura right there at the top
of our odds of calculations Robert and
it would be fair to say that a fallen
has her work cut out for her what does
she need to do to have a chance to win
this match I'm a silent therefore have a
second because it's gonna be such a
tough task for her of course a car is
the odds-on favorite and he's earned
that being one of the best players in
online chess history so I don't haven't
answered that question Danny I wish I
did I've been looking up her games and
also looking at Cara's games trying to
figure out some weaknesses but at the
end of the day even if the score is in
Yvonne's favor heading into the bullet
knocked Moore's bullet prowess will make
sure absolutely certain that he's
winning his match well he's obviously
one of the most feared online chess
players ever and considered by many to
be the best Blitzen bullet of course
he's had a couple of tough matches
against Magnus in this very tournament
but otherwise we know that a cardinal
Kimura brings a lot to the table and
that's why you see the stats and odds
being the way they are so we're gonna
talk a little bit at throughout the day
about the next SCC matchup coming up as
well want to remind everybody while I
have your full attention that we will be
here on Sunday night as well so this is
a very very busy week one to start given
that you've already seen as we said
Aronian in Caruana right now Nakamura
and Yvonne are throwing down and then on
Sunday we'll be back to see Wesley so
and Wei Yi so Robert as we bring up the
the players here so that everyone knows
they are with us and waiting Hikaru
Nakamura getting the head Bob action on
right he's got his redbull sponsor hat
he's wearing Yvonne is here with us as
well and she is ready to go these these
players have have have been have been
ready here for a few minutes so we're
going to start the games momentarily and
want to remind everybody that throughout
the day today
if you
should choose in your liking maybe you
see a beautiful tactic you like or you
just want to send a message of love to
someone on the planet any donations
during today's match whether they be bit
suits through twitch or through stream
labs will be directly added to the price
one that goes 100% to the players not to
Robert's sandwich money not to Jess calm
but only to the players and so we will
keep you updated throughout the day as
that price phone increases it's
something that we will be doing for the
remainder of the SCC season to raise
raise funds for these players as they do
amazing things on the chess board
Robert good I was I was gonna say that
hit car might need a chiropractor after
this because he's bobblehead Nakamura
right now yeah it's hurting my neck just
to look at all that movement there well
we will obviously be entertained by a
card today probably both on the chess
board and off Yvonne is she's ready to
roll we talked to her before it started
and I remembered that last year her
match though it's very early right now
in China last year she played Caruana
it's 6:00 a.m. so it's 8 a.m. right now
in China so that seems you know much
more reasonable for her I think she's
feels ready and and fresh and looking
looking ready to go so let's uh let's
get this show on the road
the matches the games have begun yep in
a car with the white pieces and the 29
92 rating he's not gonna be happy when
this day is over with his rating because
her ratings he's a 24:53 that is
severely grossly under rating her skill
obviously she just doesn't play on chest
like I'm too frequently it seems like so
hey car is not gonna be happy by days in
what he is gonna well I don't know drop
well below is 29.92 current rating yeah
likely he will I don't put the odds at a
teef on not not getting some big wins
against him and taking some of those
rating points as at very low so alright
what do we have here on the board we've
got the the famous Sakura Nakamura 1 b3
type of game going here he started with
one night of free but this is a weapon
that Hikaru plays online against
everybody regardless of the level of
competition something he's become very
good at even if it's not something he
plays over the board and more
theoretical tournaments right he's
exceptional at it
good thing for white is that your pieces
are free-flowing very easy set up to
have the bad news is you've given up the
two bishops now the reason why that can
backfire for white is that once this
bishop particular one on g7 has no
counterpart if that bishop can open
itself up for example an eventual g5 and
f4 or b6 to reroute itself via f8 it's
an unopposed dark square bishop so g5
was played perhaps the strategy plan for
b6 would have been met by the same very
same v4 idea but that's going to be the
key to Black's position she was a five
which is a good move because it forces
open the file and so now she is
something to work with
she can play the move here for example
rook a7 rook a3 even maybe working
through smarter just the hint and
entering the c3 square and start putting
pieces on that a file the bad news is
that white can actually just remove his
rook from d1 to a 1 and then compete for
that file as well so thus far a very
normal position I'm waiting for both
sides to really create some significant
chances with a set for break for black
and for white perhaps playing for b5 in
Queens that expansion yes somehow the
the rest of the the game was not being
updated I apologize for that everybody
the analysis board does indeed have the
right position I will do what I can to
fix that right now my apologies for that
whoa the analysis board yeah there that
looks for evidence today I'm seeing here
after the move Knight b3 take on c5 hey
Carter should probably take with his
night on c5 I just don't like having
them b3 in fact it's more of a weakness
than the strengths people B takes e5
back for white here well then I did with
a knight because you took back with the
pawn the b-pawn immediately that night
on b3 is a bit misplaced work will come
to be in the tackett's we're trading on
c5 here the Knights now white need not
worry and after B takes e5 you can use
the open beef off your rook but if I'm
black I'm really considering it is it
time yet to play f4 I think Yvonne will
wait she'll choose the right moment you
leave rook a three here and then follow
that out with queen a5 gaining some
steam over there on the Queen side but
seven right away can't be a bad move so
many options from black it's actually
surprisingly flexible and she played f4
immediately so seeing no downside here
well if you leave for for white you
might just be met by a pawn storm
further pawns storm with g4 so she
Hakkar it takes and she just takes back
and I think Black has nothing to worry
about in a position like this where
you're not gonna have any pawn
weaknesses you can use go Bishop takes
e5 here because you can take back with a
rook on e5 or you met with rook a one
check and devastating threats in the
back rank so after Bishop takes e5 you
have to play D takes e5 but then black
and entick on G three swap those pawns
and then take over the F line with rook
a3 and you'll note that the pawn on c5
becomes much looser you have to take
with the D pawns
Bishop takes e5 here it seems very
strong well she's thinking it over
she hasn't okay energy she decides that
she agrees with you one of the things
that will obviously be a common theme we
highlight throughout the match given
that it is Hikaru playing time on the
clock right right now Yvonne has
certainly a good position for black I
agree with you no troubles but but okay
still plenty of time even though she is
down about a minute on the clock and now
she's trying to transition to an endgame
where black would pretty much never be
able to lose so smart idea yeah and I'm
not worried about her time situation
right now considering she has nearly
three minutes the one second increment
will come in handy and actually you know
I'm very much anticipating her bullet
skill so if you see her getting the time
severe time trouble again see up quickly
she plays the bad news for her current
position is her King there's a little
bit unsafe here you know you would like
to bring your King up especially
anticipating a Queen trade but if you
difficult in G 7 I'm a little concerned
what happens is that Queen goes from f3
to f6 with the check and then that could
be quite problematic so look b8 played
she's trading off the Brooks yeah once
the rosca traded our King has no worries
whatsoever or the Queen's who it's just
the training final make sure there's no
not to major pieces just one per side he
should not be in too much danger so the
car was drawing the King out there by
poking at the h6 pawn now now with the
King come in to g7 we've got lines like
you talked about perhaps Queen afford
though is met with something like rook
to be one and and white just doesn't
have anything more after the check on f6
yeah so I think queen up for it which is
looks very threatening just could be one
trade off those rooks and say well I
have no real weakness at the poke egg
it's hard to get to the c6 bond that's a
backward punt there and on the other
hand this deep on may find its way
forward in the near future
yeah it's not feasible at all rook p1
here it should definitely be played
trade off those rooks yeah I don't know
what she's thinking about there she goes
there she goes again
no sorry partner I miss him the Miss and
the pop culture reference shame on me
it's okay okay but free after the Trey
don't see one still this feels like an
end game that black should not lose
although it's hard to hard to see if
black is is gonna have any winning
chances on the same note because it
seems like after white gets a four the
threat of playing f5 and maybe having
ideas of creating his own past pond
should be enough for for white to be
equal here even despite Yvonne already
having the past deep on and I would not
trade Queens here because the problem
with trading Queens is the white king
runs the center very quickly and the
pawn on c6 is on a white square so and
then Y can also expand with f4 f5 so
what I would do is like Queen before
keep the Queens on the board say what is
your Queen and Bishop doing for white
there no infiltration points I play
Queen before I could buy D for myself
but Bishop b3 after that just start
poking ooh okay well I guess this should
pan out as well she trades it but
immediately playing f6 I guess is the
one way she could perhaps counteract or
stop but we were saying we highlighted
that White's King is gonna get more
active in that the c6 pawn is on a light
squared therefore it's an eventual
target but if she's able to get
something like d4 bishop d5 and get her
King active quickly then she should
probably be fine despite despite going
against your advice and trading Queens
yeah I'm not loving this decision I'm
just a bit concerned about the c6 pawn
you the bishop will be tied down to it
the white king is darting straight
towards the Senators right now I put mr.
a4 and now Kenya to doubt now perhaps
King of five I guess her hope is
- if the King comes in to g4 and pokes
at g3 it may not be possible for her car
to be as aggressive with the King as
he'd like
right and I think she can trade now she
introduced in a moment because white
can't create further advancement with
this yeah past pawn at four and so the
bishops get traded again Italy just
results in a draw seems likely will be
headed for a draw on that note I think
the cars and movies King towards the
Queen side perhaps but you can never
take on c6 now with the bishop on the
edge that's the problem is if you even
if you go King DeForest III before a5 QB
6 and then the taxi six through Bishop
you can't take it because the D pawn is
very passed so it's not like there's any
work for white to go yeah I think you're
right this should just fizzle out in the
next moves yep yep okay well um a car of
deciding whether he has anything more
than just a repetition at this point
still gonna try to wiggle something
around it wouldn't be the first time
he's you know either shamelessly flagged
or swindled somebody in an equal ending
on line so that's absolutely true it's
happening you know he's definitely being
in some of those positions heels just
wipe me off the board many times so yeah
he knows the thing or two about flagging
his opponents and she's actually getting
into that territory where she's 51
seconds left it's really an easy half
point here so he shouldn't take her car
shouldn't push too much further I don't
think but for Yvonne
well she's holding well but she just
needs to stop spending so much time you
don't want to tempt a car with the flag
EMU is essentially my point yeah well I
think she's trying to make sure she
doesn't really have any losing chances
that she's not missing something but I
agree with you that the one way she
would lose this at this point is if
we're in the same spot and she's under
five seconds remember everyone this year
it's only a one-second increment in the
five men in three minutes last year's
speech as championship was two seconds
which a big big difference especially at
this level when you're if you're not pre
moving oh she's in trouble now yeah I
was gonna say I was stopping on my words
that changes that changes big-time and
now Hikaru gets the head Bob going much
more aggressively well they're they're
the kings in so let's say can you hold
this King I don't want to play King f8
and Bishop ei and just get past it I
guess you still can't she has it you
still can't take the pawn and c6o play
Bishop h5 and Bishop back to ei
something on that it should still be a
draw right because white can't trade
whoa whoa what she what was going on
that we missed there's no balance hold
that was bad that was a freak out in
time trouble she must have hallucinating
plan therefore Recaro because I don't
think there was one nope now there is
yeah now there's a plan call cuz they
take on c6 and Queen okay you need five
yeah you're keen to protect the F pawn
as well Wow so how did she
what did she calculate back here to
justify playing d4 Wow
what eight what up what a tough loss to
start today's match I think I think she
failed to recognize that she could just
trade the bishops off and it's a draw I
really think that once the king of pawn
got so advanced she was worried that
trading ambitious would lead to a
winning sort of ending for Hikaru and
well that uh was not just d4 just kind
of hand him the game she was getting him
time trouble that's really what happened
there okay well a big win for her Carl
getting getting a kind of sneaking away
with with the victory there he is the
first one on the board and still still
rocking out to whatever it is I wonder
if it's the offspring today or fee if
he's you know going with some slow jams
yeah he looks like he's just listening
some rock or something the way he's
moving his head yep
he is playing from Canada right so
that's right B maybe he's getting some
Drake going on some Celine Dion the the
Canadian playlist
what about Biebs you don't gotta have
some Justin Bieber in there no I
definitely not be very well
alright alright so what do we have here
we've got a Pierce type of position
classical structure so we're not we're
not having Kings on opposite sides of
the board for a mating net but already
feels like black is pretty comfortable
here any fawn going into an early and
early think tank to try to remember how
she wants to play this set up but I I'm
a little biased I guess because I played
so many Sicilians as black where I was
worried about getting checkmated even
though this isn't a Sicilian the fact
that black has a set up with a very very
safe King so it makes me feel like black
is pretty comfy here yeah for sure and
it's clearly we're in naka Moore's
wheelhouse where he's moving very
quickly he knows these openings he plays
on a lot on line and you see the clear
target for square now if you play Bishop
c4 I think you can get away with it from
the time being this if you take on e4
yep I'll take back and rook takes for
issue takes f7 check is the tactic that
always takes advantage of the rook being
a little too advanced in the e4 square
so she let acara take on d3 and well
there's nothing really for black to
worry about there's my business back
black is probably just better yeah and
you have the two bishops you don't lack
the same space that you do in other
appearance
situations and well already you have a
problem to e4 square so things going
very well fair hey car all right now
although that was an instructive tactic
you highlighted there I showed it for
everyone on the analysis board I think
being aware of that the common attack
common tactical idea also occurs for
black and Italian structures with the
colors reverse of this idea where the
bishop can take on f7 and you can fork
fork the the king and rook 1-1 to put in
your pocket everybody who's watching is
something to note all right but Hikaru
looks like he's just gonna be better in
the endgame with white immediately
struggling to guard the e pawn and even
if somehow I don't win it I have the
bishop pair if I'm black develop the
Bishop to e6 and you have this three on
two which probably is a much better
majority than whites four on three yep
and the b3 square being vulnerability is
annoying for white to deal with because
it might prevent you from doubling rows
Michael put my fish on b3 the tempo
let's say if it works on d1 then I can
swing my piece it's the d file that said
white is tactically hanging out his
opponent he for for the time being with
a back
check always being the issue so you can
play a move like rook a c1 I don't that
does really you who have worked d2
trying to double up the rooks but blacks
plan is very straightforward like push
b6 connector Brooks may go h6 even think
about going g5 and expanding on the
kingside the good news for white as it
mentions the e4 punt is defendant if you
play over casing one acknowledging the
fact that you can't take on e4 and so
from blacks point of view if you played
Bishop e6 I can always buy Knight d4 for
example so Knight d7 alright
94 looks yep played and watch out from
Knight takes c6 of the tactic doesn't
work now yeah but before then I moved to
b6 Nick oh yeah I was wired I I think
that worked there's a bishop on CA
ignore me no it's okay it's late there
for you it's only 8 816 Oh way past your
bedtime all right well yeah no there was
no Knight takes c6
and now Yvonne is is threatening to
maybe get the rooks doubled on the D
file especially if she can play b3
Bishop c1 was a nice quick move just to
guard a3 with the idea that she's good
now Knight takes c6 96 works now oh she
missed it
Knight takes c6 worked now everybody and
the reason was that after rook takes d1
Knight takes it unleashes a discovery
against the night so he fawn misses an
opportunity to win a pawn there and that
may be the only opportunity she gets in
this game because now that Black has
gotten the two bishops out Robert this
just feels like white is gonna be
strangled here on the Queen side this
work on c2 feels bad yeah it feels very
bad in fact it has nowhere to go so you
know if you play move like b3 of
problems in the a3 pawn and the beats of
a pawn and Bishop g5 now black can just
play f6 I'm gonna ignore it and then
look at the three on two advantage for
black on the Queen side
played b5 a5 and just continue pushing
those pawns
yeah it's unfortunate she missed that
tactic but Hikaru playing super fast
here now with 4 minutes to 2 minutes as
we said in the last game this will be a
theme throughout the match if he fawn
consistently gets under time pressure
she did last game despite playing very
well probably should have drawn that
game
um you know she eventually eventually
panicked because of time pressure so
this is this is a theme here this is it
could be where the writing is on the
wall if she if she but then again it's
hard to judge when you're playing
somebody who's really really good at
chess Robert sometimes you have to think
about things so yeah I don't know if
you've ever had that experience but
definitely definitely you know I I I'm
just seeing a little bit of shock still
from that first game and how this
position turns so quickly because hikaru
playing just instantly every single move
is yet within a couple seconds and
that's why it makes us that's what
really makes him such a hard player to
beat it's something you don't get good
positions against him yes for the most
part he is out playing you that's just a
fact but as you've seen from many of
strong grandmasters playing him you can
get good positions against him it's
converting it that's nearly impossible
yep there seems to be a lot of
discussion in the chat about whether or
not we will see an adoption today hey
Cara Nakamura has adopted a few people
in his life for those who don't speak
online chess pop culture adoption is
when you win 10 games in a row there can
be no breaks no no no losses were draws
in beneath in between those ten games so
you win ten games in a row you have
officially adopted yourself someone and
we see Eric Hanson there with the looks
like it's kind of a pacifier in his
mouth because Papa hikaru is adopting
him so maybe maybe we'll start adding
odds for adoption into the stats that we
have that we've shown odds odds of her
that we'll see an adoption during a
match that sounds like a fun a fun stat
to add I like it it'll be interesting
you know I don't know how you predict it
but if you can get that going I'm all
about it yeah f4 so the idea being if
you take on f4 the bishop Knight takes
b2 yep remove removes the guard of the
c3 Knight yes that's looking pretty and
that means that if she cannot take it
assuming we're gonna see either Knight
h1 2 f2 or Knight back to e2 black can
reinforce a bind with something like
pawn to g5 and eventually switch back to
the D file with the rook ooh so she
decides she doesn't really have a lot of
options here unfortunately but I think
we're about to see the the 1 seed move
to a 200 lead here this looks this looks
pretty rough
yeah this is not looking fun at all
right now I I know what she can do
because you can't really move the night
away the bishop protects tonight I'm p2
now 93 you wouldn't eat five pie anyway
this is that's that's true a dog just
pointed out that Hikaru is not on the
best connection you can actually see the
two bars above his above the board there
everyone the bars there representing
your local connection to the chest comm
server so the car looks like he's in a
beautiful location with what he's
looking out at but maybe not the
strongest internet so oh there he goes
now it's back yeah almost like is he
outside like I don't even know what's
going on there but it looks like he's
looking out onto the ocean or something
it looks pretty nice it's Canada is it
everywhere in Canada nice or just the
peanut hopefully both yeah
I've never been in Canada actually so
okay rook da just take the open file
looks good enough he's like - yeah this
is just pretty straightforward and she
has less than ten seconds so very
difficult to hold and not having enough
time to do it makes it even harder so
here comes the a3 pong falling yeah
Bishop d5 just don't give any counter
chances and yeah take on any three you
could also play Bishop to b3 immediately
maybe he calculated that trading on b3
probably wasn't the best option for
white but it's tough it's tough to play
yoco Nakamura and right now he faunas is
remembering that so here we go now he'll
probably put him to play the bishop back
to c4 still no reason to rush right and
only didn't take on a3 yep and look at
this now he's using his time here
because he you know he's winning
he knows he's winning and just a matter
of conversion so he's spending time at
this moment and now the two past bonds
over there is gonna easily check yep
okay and she resigns with 0.1 hey Cara
Nakamura now has a two-game lead in this
match and for all those of you who may
or may not just be joining us welcome
this is the second speed chess
championship match of the year in our
bracket we know that we've already seen
[Music]
we've actually already seen Levon
Aronian move on and so the winner of
today's match will move on to face the
winner of MDL versus Lanie or Dominguez
Perez so that should be fun as well so
make sure you mark your calendars or
clear your sundae we have another match
on Sunday wayy versus Wesley self yep
Mike's my schedule is clear Dania in
case you are concerned no again I I know
you revolve your life around chest comm
show so it's what I live and breathe for
you caught me okay can black play c5
here I see a rook on seeing a queen on
c2 I always want to play c5 yeah you do
that is the thing you do I can confirm
that you're not making that up
yeah c5 is gonna come and we're gonna
get a hanging pollen structure so c5 now
know your place for another plan that's
typical in the structure 94 is
potentially preparing ideas like f5 if
you really want to get aggressive on the
kingside but sometimes it's just a way
that black and prepare to simplify
adding a trade of minor pieces and still
going for an idea like c5 and you can
also play the other Knight to f6 and
just back it up if you don't want to
play a move like f5 and potentially
weaken your light score diagonal so
she'll take back after ooh nighty I was
gonna say we I thought we'd seen 92
there but he returns the favor puts the
night right on e5 just take it I'm the
knight yeah I was gonna say take with
the night and play Bishop e3 right
yeah or Bishop before one of those moves
I guess Bishop before is a little
strange but seems to be still possible
yeah taking it with a knight you don't
want it with a bishop give your opponent
unopposed dark-squared bishop that looks
uncomfortable so I would prefer if I'm
black just stick with the night and
after pawn takes play because you ate
three like you said yeah because you
can't really infiltrate vd7 my rooks
perfectly placed in c8 so after and if
we exchanged a bunch of pieces and
Knight takes d5 pawn takes Bishop a3
takes
4:57 I reckon see it protects my c7 pawn
which means I played Bishop c6 and just
take your rook out
that's a and Pawnee 4 is well-protected
with the bishop on e7 here so it's not
like it's been too much of a concern
about that fall to pawn being lost that
fall I said okay so she played Bishop a3
great but engaged one of those moments
where you have to do that more quickly I
feel like yeah she spent a lot of time
there over a minute on the clock before
playing Knight 65 and ended Bishop e3
yeah you can afford to just spend a
minute in a 5 minute portion I
understand that you know it's not great
decision but you could afford it but as
the time control gets quicker it's
something that I think Yvonne will have
to really work on is going with her gut
a little more stop questioning herself
she's a very very strong player
obviously so just making the moves yep
no you're right especially because it's
one of those things where right now it
seems like we're overly judging the time
management she still has plenty of time
on the clock all that stuff but as we've
already seen and as these games go on
spending 30 seconds on something you
could have played in five seconds or
even you know a minute on something you
should have played in 20 seconds it adds
up and okay well here she does have
control over the only open file should
be enough of a position for black to be
just fine but we've we've seen this
before so we'll see what happens as time
pressure and Sue's we've had our first
few donations thank you everybody
remember all donations whether via bits
or however you choose to make that go
directly into the pockets of the players
so we appreciate that they appreciate
that a4 so let's see to a5h for play on
opposite sides of the board where is y
can try to make progress from I guess
the bishop f12 g2 may force black to
take on d1 at some point and cede
control over the D file but that said it
just looks a long way away to actually
make something really work the Pawnee 4
is well defined where that bishop and it
you distract all of your pieces to
actually take the Pawnee for you lose
control the D file so yeah I guess you
can't really rush that either
I think black is totally fine here yep
and she's G catching up on the clock
because he car isn't spending some time
yeah well he's trying to think of ways
that he can create some sort of wiggle
room something worth pushing on for
right now he doesn't see much else to do
besides trade rooks and queens
potentially so one thing that's
interesting is they transition is whose
pawn might be easier to target the e4
the e5 pawn both are potentially weak
but I don't think either side really has
the enough firepower to go get to go
gather the pawn right I would say that
blacks might be a little bit weaker
because King H 2 H 3 and G for to f4 is
like something that's feasible whereas
from blacks perspective how do user King
even approach the e5 right what they
might do though is play king e 7 and an
F like now she won't I was gonna say
that one potentially instructive thing
to point out about what her car was
doing here everybody with this pawn on
h5 and the pawn on g4 is he's setting up
what's known as a grip pawn structure
where you actually have even though the
pawns are symmetrical because your pawns
are further advanced you're constantly
in a position where there may be some
tactics down the road you you you get
the King here and eventually you can
play g5 right ignore the bishop because
let's say it's gone you would create
more avenues and more potential
opportunities to get a queen despite the
pawns being structurally symmetrical so
I'm not saying it's gonna be enough to
win but I think that if he could somehow
target the e4 pawn Robert it'd be very
hard for Yvonne to ever play a move like
f5 to defend it because hey Carla's
pawns are so so advanced and those that
move like fi would create weaknesses
that that maybe maybe would be a problem
but yeah as I'm talking about this it
doesn't look like it's gonna be a
reality at least yet but it is it is
good to note that this space advantage
could be something that comes back to
buy e Fon yeah I mean they king
unfortunately for white cannot reach
that f4 square without running right to
Bishop g5 check the 413 back right so
yeah and now the the bishop on c1 can't
move either because the pawn to h3 will
be hanging it's the only way to make any
semblance of progress with beads and
where came from to d1 to d2 to c3 and
played before but it doesn't really make
progress just trading off more pawns
it's not like you have any major pieces
to start pushing forward and using
open file so they're sort of repeating
moves I think this game should just
fizzle out Oh Carl won't let it happen
so easily yeah I guess if you could put
the King on c3 and the bishop on d2 to
play imaginary chess and then play
before because the bishop on d2 is
guarding the b4 pawn through the king
the King may be threatening to go to d4
in some spots but even that would likely
just run into a move like pollen c5
check so it just it doesn't seem that
either side really has an ability to get
to one of these magic squares two to
Underminer or attack the weak pawn so
agreed town population us boring town
population in this position and shout
out to all the fans in chat the one and
only chess bey all of those who are with
us thank you for thank you for being
here a little bit of a different time
normally we do these things in the
morning shout out to our last bit
donation there from big noble yeah
they're just repeating moves that seem
so many King moves in the recent stretch
I'm waiting for this game to be a draw
so we can move on to the next one yeah
oh and NJ Greg just in JC air and Jay
Greg the baller wow look at that
I love our team working so hard to keep
some of these Evo's updated we have a
tilt emote now which I think was added
in honor of the one and only Fabiano car
Juana's tilting performance whoa what
just happened here sorry I wasn't paying
attention this looks bad for white he so
he went f3 or F for allowing a pissant
just trying to change out the pawn
structure yeah and that does not look
like a good transition for for white at
least I don't think black can do
anything like where's your King can't
move into the game your pawns while
they're double and isolated to protect
where your two bishops so I think after
a takes before a takes before well you
can just go king d7 q 1777 it sound like
white can attack anything I there so I
think he carves doing one of those moves
where you emphasized that the position
is so equal that even if I give myself
terrible looking position wait that both
iPod
Bishop a3 wait this is this is bad for
white now you have to a king up forward
and defend the pawn yeah black no g5
check and despite what we said earlier
about whites pawns being further
advanced now they're also much weaker
than they were before so he's all in hey
Cara was tilting his own position
actually yeah he's made some really bad
decisions here well I guess the the
desperate there was no reason to be
desperate given the match situation and
you would say that maybe he feels that
he can afford to kind of push in what a
game but if he phone gets a win here and
that gives a little bit of confidence a
little bit of momentum who knows so that
this could be one he regrets I think he
wants to win every single game that's
you know because he's getting one rating
point per win oh so so far I've seen
that that he can't even afford a draw to
keep his rating as high as it is but
yeah you know he's down upon now just
down a clear pawn so question 7 can she
can black win so how does she she likes
the bishop on e5 to keep protection of
c7 okay so now that she's back it up to
d6 I think she'll try to start bringing
the King in over here to the Kings side
King g7 King f6 you can also play King's
c8 to b7 if he wants she was a 5 okay
and where does her King get to that's I
guess we can play g6 at some point so
play Bishop f8 in g6 but okay I'm not
seeing total progress here so if she
puts the bishop on f8 and pushes g6
she's g5 or g6 she's not worried about
the poem becoming a weak but again even
if you get that it's still hard to see
progress so despite a car was super
aggressive approach and the fact that
you know black is up a healthy pawn
still feels like the most likely result
is a draw yeah
and something tells me that Hikaru likes
his chances so much in a time scramble
that he's he's playing for a win right
now is playing for a win right now right
as crazy as that sounds but I know you
you finish my sentence because you knew
what I was gonna say that's exactly what
a car would be thinking that he's he's
capable of doing
he's down a pawn has no no justification
to be trying
for anything but a draw but wouldn't be
the first time o b6 is a threat now
watch out okay
g v g5 he's gonna play g5 and guys Ford
uncle bunk that's their grip the grip
comes into play everybody these are the
types of tactics you have when your
pawns are more advanced than your
opponent's despite complete symmetry
este carro takes a confident swig of his
redbull this is exactly the type of
thing to take note of that you can make
a sacrifice that you wouldn't otherwise
be able to do purely because in end
games it's not often how many pawns you
have but who gets a queen first and his
the slacker and he's gonna flag her just
whistle
this is free bishop bananas from the
perspective that he karo has no
justification for playing the way he did
yet we knew exactly what he was doing
that he was playing for a wind down a
pawn and a bishop ending amigo wait why
bishops ok this pushes e pawn you gotta
put Bishop g7 to keep the H farm this is
very easy he's six to seven we may have
a two bishop checkmate on the board if
we get lucky yeah this is amazing she's
gonna resign yep amazing is what that
was right there I mean seriously and it
frustrating to be in Yvonne's shoes I
mean she had no reason to think that she
should lose that game but what did we
say earlier in the in this in the that
game Robert we talked about to the
time-management earlier when it didn't
seem as important and I came back to
bite her yep this is it's just
unfortunate because of course if this
was a classical game then she would have
had no problem defending but we can't
keep saying our time ticking down and it
goes to show we made a comment and then
move Knight takes d5 lol Bishop a3 you
and I talked to Ed immediately and if
we're seeing it there's no doubt in my
mind that she's seeing it but she's just
not playing it as quick and of course we
don't have the responsibility of the
players do if we don't have you know too
worried that the result may hurt hurt us
emotionally all that stuff so we can
just suggest something and if it's wrong
well it doesn't affect this but at a
certain moment you have to give
you're sort of perfectionism and we've
talked about this about ourselves Danny
that sometimes we just spend too much
time trying to find the perfect move and
it really comes back to haunt us so I
think Yvonne this game she's playing
very quickly she knows that she should
get an opening advantage with the white
pieces against appearance but missed
opportunities as far as yep the story of
two games really that were missed
opportunities precisely because it was
self induced time trouble right the
first game was one that she shouldn't
have lost so she's really done pretty
well as black actually from the
perspective that had two positions as
black she had no business losing but
because of time pressure she wasn't able
to hold up against Hikaru's Hakkar was
poking and prodding that he does so well
but dumb okay so let's talk about this
one here she does have an opening
advantage this pawn on d5 represents
significantly more space for white and
Bishop h6 is nice a floor is a good move
that keeps blacks pawns here on the
queenside kind of kind of stuck and
preventing sicilian-style expansion and
just by 94 like d to cover this should
be the point I might be for everybody's
you can't take on d5
well maybe you can that's actually now I
started second-guessing myself ah
because you're saying that he'll just go
all-in and open up his King and doesn't
care cuz the plot is a pulling yep okay
but she did it and he didn't take it on
d5 but now you definitely don't want to
take on d5 for blacks or eighty-six pawn
is hanging so if you're white you
consider playing h4 or maybe Queen g5 so
you can threaten Knight a5 check that
could be a bit of a nuisance yeah I like
Queen g5 but I also like just the
overall structure here for white Robert
if she plays Bishop of three to guard d5
this rook on d1 has sort of served its
purpose maybe flip it over to the e-file
and target the e7 pawn right that's a
Marco hop structure we have here and
white should be better if you can just
start exerting pressure against the
backward e7 pawn so right and blacks
real source of counter plays the C file
the knight is sort of stuff to c3 and
maybe black will take on i.t five to c4
as a source of counter play she plays
rook c1 for that very exact purpose that
now my policy to I don't have to worry
about forever if my Knight moves from C
directly see for myself and ninety five
played now still can go rook e1 as you
suggested yep once more the pawn on d5
is hard
take that pond with the pawn on a six
hanging that's a very important pond to
the queenside structure so Queen III
rookie won all of these moves seem to
make perfect sense Queen g5 is a third
option no but I think you're right these
moves are intuitively easy to play as
you understand the structure so it's
something we're right here it might you
know she's step tending a lot of time
here already right she spent 46 seconds
on the last move and and she's on pace
to do the same here so this is where it
starts to be tough and as you said
easier for us to say right but I think
you have to at some point you have to
remember that a lot of times in blitz
just the fact that you're playing
confidently and quickly it's just as
important as playing the best move a lot
of the time so yep okay
Queen III goes for it almost 3000 of you
with us now thanks for being here thanks
for spending your Thursday night with me
and the boss sir your mom likes when I
call you Bob right she's listening right
now she's probably very mad at you yeah
nice a nice thing game on Knight f3 is
that after 94 I can take and your b6
pawn hangs oh very nice yeah so you're
offering the knight trade without any
consequence the neck come to c4 because
if I wasn't gonna take on c4 you're nice
to know we might be two pawns so I get
away with taking on c4 and taking on b6
and now if you play Knight takes f3 for
black white just takes back with the
bishop on f3 you solidify this d5 pawn
which is really encroaching on black
space you're restricting blacks pieces
yep and well we can start if we start
training the Knights for example and
Knight coming to e4 after that then Y
can expand on the Queen side at long
last by playing c4 before and things
like that yeah and that's a great point
Robert obviously you highlighted earlier
that kind of the C file is awkward for
white and and that that might be one
thing black has going for them so if if
white could move the night and get c4
before you start to realize White has a
three-on-two pawn majority over here and
again blacks majority is not effective
here because the e7 pawn is backward in
fact him certainly make me think that
Hikaru might try to find some way to
aggressively play e6 at some point if
you can get away with it the the risk
removing this e-pawn everybody is that
it always opens up attacking chances
against the D pawn yep but okay Queen c5
this is a good move for black yeah I
think well if I take on e5 you can take
on e3 first and so you give white that
sort of awkward backward epon but at the
same time black love double e pawns
himself so if I find ninety five you
take on e3 and then at the end of the
way white has efore to which and where
white also has d6 just trying to trade
off that past deep on moving forward
this the e Pawnee up to d6 square for
your rooks so I expect her to play Queen
at four because he's thinking for so
long that she just wants she's gonna
avoid it all together but I think you
can get away with 965 between 63 pawn t3
pawn takes e5 d6 and I'm sort of taking
over the default become most useful file
yep yeah well at what I was highlighting
is that white could even play e4 at the
end of that line Robert cuz the King
comes to f2 and III holds down the e4
pawn which frees up the night and again
White has a majority over here on the
Queen side she goes for your line with
d6 but I'm not sure that a slower
approach there of efore king of two King
III wasn't wasn't also good yeah I
definitely agree with you there I think
that you know she's sort of seized at
the moment here she saw that sure
working it to d6 why should probably be
better here so now take take and rook b6
just get your rook behind that pawn
actually just go and win it looks pretty
nice for for white so Rikuo actually
rook b6 I'm starting think of exchange
sacrifices rook takes c-3po in 95 it's
getting complicated here
yeah 95 rook b5 not possible because of
Knight to c3 everybody which would be a
whole lot of forks in fact I'm sure
that's what she's thinking of right now
Hikaru kind of kind of calm there right
no longer rocking the magical head Bob
she decides she's just gonna go take b5
right away right pawns upon
yeah this is tonight g3 okay
conversation where's this bishop going
to you played Bishop d3 black can buy e
for for example and keep at that Bishop
the good thing about black playing efore
from White's point of view is that the
bishop on b7 looks worse but taking off
the bhishma off the board so he went
Bishop b4 yes like that I mean as King
as Gambino is flexing the four key mode
and the Chad is right you can't move the
bishop from d3 without Knight e to check
coming in and Bishop before the strong
move yeah and so what it's a knight c3
so Brooke takes c3 don't we have a
problem with that fork again yeah I work
town yeah this is not looking very good
XD 3 C takes D 3 rook takes c3 no take
on c3 first ok take a rip cakes and then
Bishop takes D 3 and you win a piece at
the end of the line so it works well
beams yeah so now maybe Bishop takes e4
is that an intermediate I think it's the
only way yeah bishop before the point
everybody is that yes the four Captains
but the rook on c3 hangs at the end so
we'll see what Hakkar was calculated I'm
sure he's anticipating Bishop takes e4
and she's in time trouble once more this
is really not looking good for her
yep 17 seconds of counting down so she
did take on e4 and now rook takes III I
guess what has to play King f2 and then
rook takes e4 King takes g3 we're not a
weird end game with rook and for two
reps and four was two risks and four but
the the pawns are split for white which
is either a huge advantage or a huge
disadvantage right here in this position
because of the exposed King on g3 I'm a
bit concerned about how this will pan
out I like what she's doing here though
I think the all-in approach with the
pawn that you already had your rook
behind
basically reminding a car that if he
plays for rookie 2 and takes he may end
up having to take some sort of Perpetual
because this queen is coming but I think
it something tells me he Cara won't take
Perpetual he'll try for mate so how does
that happen something with f5 and f4 f5
for sure
yes oh he's playing tickle right now
which makes sense when your opponent
only has 10 seconds he's just trying to
trying to poke and prod but but it's
risky right I mean it the nice thing is
he probably has a perpetual no matter
what but she's already in a position
Robert where even if there is a mate and
he pushes f5 she just has to go go right
ahead and just push the C pawn and and
hope there isn't one yeah he's doing
great job I'm using his time in critical
moments here so I would try it because
that we see f5 at c7 and rook h2 is that
an option to try to check me in on the
third-ranked so you said rook each
module okay fi first c7 and rook to h2
threatening which takes h3 and rook d3
made everybody to buy you mates you have
King g3 there's right and working it
looks like it's just uh just more tickle
but maybe maybe after f5 c7 can I go g5
34 check and rookie 3 mate King III f4
no this is me ah she just made it
herself
yeah rook after you - rookie recheck
rookie 3 King G for rookie 3 rook oh
wait he blundered see a queen protects
h3 see a queen protects h3 there's no
way he oh no she she resigned a winning
position for her was that really winning
yes you protect h3 but CA equals Queen
oh my gosh Wow
it's because he caught removed the wrong
rope to the g5 he wants his work from G
the D to the g2 with check Brown the
rook from e3 to g3 he would have been
winning instead he quickly moved the
wrong rook
yes he's shaking his head now looking
around like oh my gosh I just blundered
that game he's like he's like oh crap
that was a mistake yeah he's funny yeah
Danny we know we absolutely know he's
gonna mention it in the postgame
interviews posting
say I think well in that fourth game
actually I was miss that I wasn't
checkmating yeah and so I got lucky
there but that was that's one good the
one great that what not one but what are
the great things about her karo is he
always wears his emotions on on his
sleeve and so you just know how he feels
at all times he's still doing it and I
know that you have your a car Fathead
somewhere of course I do
but I've got every Hikaru Fathead the
anyone could ever ask for
so do you have the Hikaru absolute shock
Nakamura I know you're right I have
angry Hikaru and happy hit Carl because
I couldn't spend that much money on fat
heads my own little weird games I play
the first time he karma saw the fat
heads in my office he said dude you're
weird yeah I mean he's not wrong and I
said I said dude you're welcome
okay amazing he's he's still shaking his
head like he's really bothered by that
yeah well he just blundered into mated
it Yvonne is unfortunately right now
just seems a little shook right I
wouldn't say the tilt the tilt is is
there already but she knows she has it
in she has a tough day ahead of her she
is the 16 seat hit car was the one seed
but she's had three games that arguably
could have had different results right
two games she should have drawn in that
last game hey Carter blundered into a
into a lost ending but but she kind of
already had her mind made up that she
was mated so those are the things we
highlight and we suggest the word tilt
because they're sort of emotional things
that have not necessarily everything to
do with the X's and O's yeah it's one of
those situations that really illustrates
why they're they're good moves and
they're really fast moves and hikaru
tends to do both but in that end gaming
Yvonne just did not have the time to
come up with the resources to save her
so I'm Queen g5 here and this particular
Liam that was a good decision because
now g2 mate is threatened so you have to
trade Queens and once this Queen trade
happens 94 I just take this on e4 and
black enters a great end game yeah this
is phenomenal it mainly everybody
because the D pawn is just the only
positional weakness on the board hey
Carl get live one
go ahead pawns hanging Danny rook FD one
Knight takes e5 that's fine just
straight up rook fd1 Knight takes e5 cuz
that's a pin how is it that every time
we have a pin it's with a rook I don't
even know how oh he's shaking his head
he missed that yep he looks a
it looks a little bit frazzled right now
well you fall it needs to get a win she
needs to stop the bleeding and get a win
so will will go an extra pawn be enough
we'll see but she's up on the clock -
this is actually by far her best game
was jinxed her she's no longer up on the
clock but yeah whoops no but you're
right though a much much closer setting
here on time although what's she
thinking about now right okay she's up
upon she can she can decide well I think
she's probably calculating things like
rook d8 do you want to allow take on e5
trade on d1 and then take e4 or does she
actually like the knight on the board
she decides she wants to keep the knight
which i think is the right decision to
play for a win bring the knight to f6
and and then work on your two-on-one
advantage over here yeah so right now
you can't come to f6 Bishop d3 but you
can go to c5 and then take on d5 next
move probably yeah HC v IC 5 makes sense
what actually makes a lot of sense so no
e 5 honestly Pony 5 just the thing I
like about 95 - is that bishop of 3 can
be met possibly by g4 mmm
tempting we'll see
okay we'll see if she goes for that well
something interesting Dani is that white
does not want to play d6 and that looks
like the move you do want to play
because it creates a further advance
past pawn right it's very easy for black
to come out for that pawn so I'm yogi
black can't even play Brooke c2 and just
ignore that whole configuration over
there on the Kings side yeah good point
I think we'd be more likely to see hit
hard Oh take on e6 and try for something
with the with the - Brooks being open
and the bishop try to simplify but okay
even rook e8 it makes sense I mean at
this point I think that she points out
what you said which is that d6 is really
not a threat right because that Paul
would be so weak yeah you you just
ignore it and pick it well just put your
piece rook on d8 and then you can go
after it's yeah so she makes a trade
King is still safe now it's time to go
to work go get the a pawn or something
close to it
can rookie seven prophylaxis the biggest
worry you have here again is on the
clock but this position is
straightforward enough that it that
shouldn't be as much of an issue
Danny it's a I agree with you but I'm
also like interested in the twitch chat
because I mean compared to all these
random comedians I have Dmitri I was
both say to meet you Snyder's chess
player to meet you Martin kyle mooney a
guy I don't know what's going on here
but somehow I'm reminding people of
various comedians today by the way I
like to meet you Martin dishes a book
was a very funny book that I read a
while back so Dimitri mertens great yeah
agreed
but chest I love blacks position
ariyaphon can just go well many
different good moves
yeah King up six following night II 6 is
perfectly reasonable rookie six actually
mate just trading Brooks off play Brooke
a3 here to keep that rook tied down to
the second rank
agreed yeah this should be pretty
straightforward but again you start
looking at time on the clock and uh and
you wonder why and what she's thinking
about it again a lot of it has just
happened that's part of the advantage of
being an online blitz aficionado that
hikaru is right he just doesn't spend
time on moves that he doesn't need to
spend time on right and I think that
chess players are patient and
disciplined by nature right and so if
you don't play a lot of online blitz for
you or you don't always need to be as
patient or double--triple-check things
you really just need to trust your
intuition I think it's hard sometimes
for players who don't play a lot online
to break that habit Robert it's one of
the things that they have that makes
them a good chess player right they're
there they're thorough they they you
know they really check things and and
they really want to calculate and be
sure but sometimes because what what was
she thinking about over k3 not anything
worth 20 seconds right
no she's being a little bit too
fastidious with her decision-making
she's used to safest cities I did that
is a word that is way too advanced for
the show
okay well I'll tell you but you know
rookie two years winnings good as your
mom's watching doesn't mean you need to
impress her with the vocab I don't need
to do anything to press my mom she loves
me no matter what Danny
well yeah you're right the play a six
and B five and do it quickly
a 65 and a two are all hanging take
everything
chest pain 94 says fastidiousness is a
great word Thank You Ches Bay
all right about her second pun she still
has b5 coming
I get a feeling we're about to see our
first Yvonne Winn Hikaru removes the
headphone kind of for a second
he's going into thought here about how
to make this as interesting as possible
but he's just down to pawns yep and so
what's he's like h4 hoping that she
takes on h4 anybody work at 4 check I
miss at least I'm assuming a sort of a
Hikaru Oh a nice move rook Seto just
trading off well actually so you trade
off on c6 yeah but then he gets the h6
bullet this has become
but then my King just darts from a 5d
for c3 and that should be enough for a
win yeah this is this is a winning
endgame ok yeah that makes sense
they can also very easy help us the pawn
advance yeah but the rule could even
just go to f6 and hold everything
f7 the F file which by the way prevents
the White King from rushing in and and
this Kings just gonna come over here on
Queen so okay so King D for probably we
have to see f3 and the King try to come
around as much as defense is not in
Hikaru's nature I think he's gonna have
to play some here well he she has plenty
of time in this game so actually she's
doing well in the clock and with that
past b-pawn just rolling this should be
pretty simple okay why did that move I
would have liked King c4 immediately I
think she's just being patient yeah it's
a rook c5 then pushed that beep on the
f7 pawn is not important because you
take that pawn you're still not creating
a passed pawn with my yellow just
doesn't have enough time to win f7 and
g6 and get anything else going here so
should be pretty straightforward here
for our first victory for the underdog
ya know it's a and a good one at that it
seems like she stole that ePHI pawn very
quickly and now it's very simple
conversion okay so be to be to the rook
comes to be six white plates rooks black
plays rook c4 which threatens rook b4
and that's gonna force the sacrifice on
b2 and uh and black wins easily
everybody so I'm not exactly sure what
she's thinking about obviously there are
outside shots that white sacrifices the
F pawn and then creates an outside
passer but there's just not enough time
kicking c2 also does the trick I'm not
sure if it was any better than rook c4
to try to walk but I think work c4 was
better because white could have went f4
earlier and looked like instead of King
g3 for me that was another purpose of
the rook being on the fourth-ranked was
to prevail this is not winning is it
winning
so if g6 no jisuk is not winning Kenny
g3 hitting me I don't think this is
winning the King doesn't get back in
time King III g7 rook c8 no no he's okay
II think King III g7 I have rook c1 okay
then I go King h5 or something I'd a
degree oh yeah you're right and Hikaru
knows it too hey Caro is uh is happy
about it yeah this is this is a good
instructive point that very often the
only way you can really win these
endings you have to get your King back
and the straightest possible path so
this whole idea with king c2 and
queening where she ended up taking on be
one with the king as well lost her the
game Brooksie for as we were
highlighting you need to came to come
back as quickly as possible in these
kind of games rook c4 would have been a
big difference it would have forced rook
B to everybody and after King takes the
the black king is is essentially two
squares faster to getting back because
anything that goes to to the d3 square
is not nearly as good as d4 again if
you're evaluating those endgame is a
good instructive takeaway is you have to
find the fastest path back for the
often people focus on the rook and think
I need my rook behind the pawns is that
usually the rook has nothing to do with
whether you'll win you have to get your
King back as fast as possible yeah
Wow gives us some instructive things to
offer to the fans in the chat but a
heartbreaking non victory there for
Yvonne yeah that's that stuff and it's
funny though then breathe breathe it's
funny though that Nakamura has lost
rating points despite being a four and a
half half right now and that's just what
happens when he founds rating is so much
lower on chess calm it's gonna be a huge
like I said before the start of the
match naka is gonna lose rating points
start this match even if he wins by a
ton
yep well they are both both focused here
shifted shifted off-camera slightly
that's what happens really gets the
running joke I try it
Robert you're with me before the show
start I worked so hard to try to see
what things are gonna look like on
camera ask them to move around and it's
always in an unpredictable position that
they end up in and they really tell you
so many times I promise you I'm gonna
stay in this position I'm not gonna move
this why would I move this way when I
miss it this isn't quite as bad as the
as the Fabi for head fro which led to
our Photoshop contest but you know I
don't think we've seen her carros mouth
all game and we lost we lost sight of
Yvonne's right eye yeah and in this
position spam losing sight has no I kind
of he does this thing where he knows
he's getting himself in bad positions
right but this I'm just getting a
position but right now look at the
kingside there no black pieces that are
even near that guy and made me think
that was there a Grieg if there wasn't a
bishop takes h7 tactic there everybody
because in the end black has bishop of
five to guard h7 but but roberts right
and then whenever you have a position
with no minor pieces protecting the king
you have to start looking at forceful
ways to break open the structure because
usually the mating net is is not far
behind 84 is a good move you can't take
on c4 because queen d3 it's both the h7
square and c4
yeah the Queen D 3 now looks great
highlight that for everybody here that
would have been a another fork
she goes for it Oh Queen D one check I
wanted it I wanted in tactics here she
does it for slightly different reasons
than my mating net but I'm glad I got
what I wanted and she should get a
victory here this one should be a
victory not so easy yet because the
situation with the pawn and see for
Bishop f5 coming at some point you mean
to make sure that you don't allow some
Bishop d3 but no this is clearly amazing
for white she has plenty of time in the
clock now you have to go g5 for black
and hope that by creating more
weaknesses you're not just getting
crushed oh this is this is not good yeah
no she's she's on pace to get this one
here so weird to put the bishop I want
to take on d6 and and just get a million
pawns take on d6 f5 but there's no
reason for me to to do any kind of
sacrifice yeah you you're going crazy
over there yeah not necessary right just
back up the bishop to even h2 I mean I
wonder if okay she goes to d2 which
makes sense because it prevents that
five everyone now that two pieces are
hitting the cheap pawn black can't
afford to push but but I feel like this
should be pretty straightforward for
white the rook on a6 is completely out
of play white is already very quickly
gonna be bringing heat to the e-file and
I would even do so at the risk of the a
pawn falling honestly although maybe not
I guess because if the a pawn falls the
c4 pawn is not far after so that's a
problem yeah I would do it though I'm
all about exactly yeah there's also so
that makes sense now if your Caro traded
she could under her C pawns play C 4 and
have a new new target on a5 yeah this is
great
that's a good move then she can bring
the Brooks to the e-file next
so I'd go Queen c7 is black and just
arrived at Queen d8 same idea that this
Queen can get in trouble with rook b6
being a threat so Queen B to back and
now I'm it you can say work eight you
want here because I think after Queen
takes a four you can play Queen b5 been
sort of a funny-looking maneuver but
your previous force out of play please
do not repeat moves here I'd be very sad
no no II fought no II fun no he's
shaking his head because he's surprised
I think she at this point was happy just
to get something on the board but that
was definitely a Miss evaluation I loved
your rook 81 idea although it was my
idea at first but I'll give it to you it
was your idea but that's we use each
other to become a better that's sweet me
and you together one plus one equals
five yeah it's like that mikhail tall
quote right that's not just because I
dropped out of high school the tall
chord right I'm gonna take my opponent
into a deep dark forest where two plus
two equals five that's right and there's
only one way out you know so like come
on tall
okay so naka repeating some strange like
in openings but not that strange that's
pretty normal set up actually in this
one yeah but that that that's a
disappointing one there I mean it's one
that you not get you're not gonna get
many chances to push there and against
Hikaru but uh but she had one there so
and and I think from a principled
perspective when he plays dubious
openings that we know Hikaru can do from
time to time I think you'd really have
to try hard to uh to get those wins
because now we're in much more of a
mainline structure Kings Indian attack
White's playing for f4
actually Hikaru won a really nice game
on the black side of this structure a
similar structure against Federico Perez
poncy annotated that game for my chest
life column so I yeah he played in the
black side of a position like this and
he won a really nice game and what he
did the thing look black would love to
do is trade off the two bishops and one
of the Knights for whites
two knights in the dark square bishop
leave no now you don't want do it but
before I have five was played leave
white with his LightSquared Bishop now
but this exchange happened the lesser of
Bishops actually a good piece because
there's no Pawnee for blocking its path
and now from black you have to worry
about any any time like an F takes d5
Knight f4 sort of thing happening the
good news is this bishop on c1 is kind
of stuck there for the time being and
you have to move your knight from d2 and
we need to really make progress but h4
idea being Knight g3 maybe your knight
or pond and go to h5 and I'm starting to
like hey Cara's position more and more
so it's um yep
looking pretty solid and here we see
Yvonne is probably gonna spend some time
what's she gonna do here Queenie eight
stops the powerful going to h5 but I
don't really love my queen on the e8
square but let's see what is she so she
won Queen e8 and my reaction is how do I
get a piece of rook to e1 but I don't
know if I love my rook e1 for white that
seems very strange though because the
clay will just go into h5 an h4 pawn is
weak so you have to do something about
that threat Queen h5 trying to win the
h4 pots may just 93 now and you know
well actually three maybe pawn takes f4
huh and then h5 yeah the age 93 it was
plead Knight age five is gonna be really
really annoying here to deal with I
think that and just nice what happened
black is up a pawn temporarily we're not
gonna keep it Bishop e5
isn't just maybe she doesn't want to
keep it
well she's not keeping it for a long
night b3 hits the c5 pawn if you played
b6 is black you're gonna run right into
rook e1 and that might just cost you a
piece honestly so King h8 played to c5
is a free pawn no yeah that doesn't make
a lot of sense
seems like b6 was the the best option
there this isn't good
this is really not good for any fun yep
in fact it's almost a reasonable
positions weird to say that one material
pieces on the board I agree but no it's
there's almost no lose here Ricky want
every move White's advantage is
increasing and rook e1 might just win a
piece because if you move your queen off
the e-file a bishop takes c6 and you're
threatening to do something similar to
it right now
if you move the knight away from from c6
white can take on d7 and then take e5
immediately so I think I wouldn't be
surprised if we see
Grichuk makes a very interesting comment
we think we think Sasha for being here
hanging out in chess calm but he was he
was very critical of Yvonne's draw in
the last game so yeah I cam can't blame
him but love to see grishnack in the
chat obviously an incredibly strong
player he'll be playing soon enough
against yon new palm Nashik so right
so night f7 let's play rook e7 I just
keep your rook on the board
rookie seven the Knights coming into f6
we may have a fancy schmancy mate over
here at age seven let's see okay captain
- nice everybody of course the Brooke is
not worth capturing at all the dark
squares will be a serious problem but
white white is of a piece right just a
full piece yeah a full piece that is
that that is what they say sad news
taking on c2 to trade Queens white will
take a three and again taking e5 not
only is it not enough material because
then white has two pieces for the rook
probably the mating net is is still
pretty strong here on the dark squares
Queen take C - no okay trades and then
takes but still Knight a second Bishop
takes d4 that works 9 f6 check take h7
was also a nice new pass bond over there
so interesting we've died of four just
to protect d3 I guess to play h5 g6
yeah rook cheap one like that okay or
grab the C file and do things the
old-fashioned way over here on g7 Bishop
takes d4 now three pawns Bishop f6 d3 is
protected yep
resign time know still playing not yet
here comes the rook rook c7 or not
I mean 96 just I guess 96 is just as
good maybe not I don't know actually
yeah 94 now rook c7 just make sure that
rook can't block him the seventh rank
this is painful
rook c7 do it seven probably enough free
fun to throw in the towel here and a two
minute time advantage to go with it yeah
it's tough man feels bad man it's tough
man although I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say there will be no adoption today
so I'll say that I think Yvonne has
obviously kind of reset reset the
potential adoption with the last couple
draws that maybe could have been wins
but I'm gonna say that that doesn't
happen today you want to take me up on
that you think it does happen and bullet
baby could potentially happen in bullet
I don't really see it happening but I
also I'm not sure I see if I'm getting
more than four points that was my
threshold honestly her getting four
points because a car was just so strong
so fast he's the favorite in the overall
tournament but I mean these in these
segments he's been showing that even if
he gets shaky positions he's so quick
that'll make his opponent nervous she'll
agree the drawers and well nearly
winning positions just to stop the
bleeding
so yeah which is tough right it's tough
and obviously it's definitely I think we
deserve or she deserves us to be
critical that but it's also I think
trying to get some momentum back in her
favor here her car was trying to maybe
take care of something else
I don't know innocent he stepped away
for the moment looks like shadow to a
jack
Jack see who just gifted a sub the
second gifted sub on our channel thanks
to everybody who's here all 3,500 of you
on chest comm TV and twitch.tv slash
chest
and in the chest calm chat if you want
to go and login and see see Grichuk you
should go ahead and do that what is that
what are we seeing in the reflection on
Nakamura camera there
what Tower is that I've never been a
canvas that's uh that's where the aliens
land I was genuinely curious but now
it's it looks like it's just a water
tower okay I'm just curious maybe I'm
not trying to pop your bubble about
things that aren't as impressive as you
think they are but you know it reminds
you of Seattle yeah yeah oh he's back
Hikaru is back
and Robert has muted himself because of
the car alarms I saw an ambulance II the
lights of an ambulance about to go
through so I muted myself just so
everyone else didn't have to hear one
day we're gonna move you to a safe place
Robert I feel like I'm in a very safe
place thank you very much
yo so I was told by our handyman Pete
that's Harbor Center tower in Vancouver
oh okay there you go Pete
I'm coming through even before stat man
could I'm surprised Mike Mike should be
feeling ashamed right now that's usually
my clients thing I'm disappointing them
disappointed in the stat boy right now
but proud of Pete one of the best things
about when Grichuk is online is he often
plays guest the move likes himself some
guests the move but our last guest the
move title player was just a spot fan so
that's not good that may indicate some
poor chess being played or just all
right Bishop - C - I like it
bring the Bishop to b3 d5s a weakness
maybe I can take on a four so here's
again partly due to the whatever the
whatever the services that hikaru needed
to attend to when he disappeared for a
minute but regardless of what that was
he is down more than a minute on the
clock here and so we have a rare a rare
situation yeah we don't see that very
often in his position isn't terrible but
I also don't tend to love these
structures for black give this e six
ball in this backward rookie one rook c1
from white we're not we're just again a
French right now yep you know how we
feel about the French but this is one of
those rare French's where we might be
okay with black yeah no I definitely
feel okay here yeah because the deep one
is just as much of a weakness as
anything on e6 and with the open F file
black has decent looking counterplay
yeah g5 I don't like that move yes I
understand the intention yeah I expected
95 to wait that was a blunder writing by
both why couldn't black have taken on a
mine no there was no for Connie to cuz
the night
yeah there's nice you know I was trying
to go Bishu a six as well but the night
still is on c3 so it doesn't change so
okay so c5 perhaps just rookie one here
yes highlighted her last two moves
before she played it maybe maybe if I
keep highlighting her move she'll play
fast maybe no but I like rookie one
mainly because there is no threat of
taking e5 and then a fork on d4
everybody because Y can take f4 oh maybe
her car was gonna go for it but if but
if she takes a four oh look at this
well I saw that coming but I'm not sure
how much I quite love it because King G
to d4 Knight e4 comes in the night is
jumping it to f6 yeah and if Bishop to
b7 pinning the night I move my bishop
away and I rook protects the e4 right I
was gonna see even have moves like Queen
g4 but yeah I think just moving the
bishop keeping the peace would make
sense so this feels a little suspect yep
she enjoyed as a carnal going for some
sort of long-term peace a code Bishop d7
no this is has to be the only option he
had and all of a sudden he he gives his
WTF a car oh I browse well if you take
on e3 I guess play Knight f6 check right
that's seems pretty straightforward and
the very least my knight is planted on a
dark square where you can't check it out
so negative six check King g7 and maybe
I play Queen c2 there just go for
checkmate
yeah our Queen f3 actually hitting the
rook on a it's also possibility I'm not
sure I can think about trying brooke
takes III have so many good options for
white yeah
yeah this looks great for you fun so
plain I have six check what's wrong with
that
maybe she's considering keeping them any
for for some reason to hit the g5 pawn
but not if six check just looks you
can't take it on sister your Queens
hanging on d8 yeah what is she thinking
about we're getting one of those moments
yep you just have to make your move you
have to make your move because there's
just nothing better to do right and you
just again it's hard again because some
of these attributes whoa she brings the
knight to a different direction or what
make them strong chess players but still
blitz and rapid really challenge the the
parts of us that don't trust our
intuition because you can keep saying
you're in a good position but time is
part of the game so if you lose because
you miss manage time earlier in the game
then deeds you know it's still a loss
right so what's going on now it looks
like all of a sudden the Knights on d6
which is still very strong
Black is up upon and also up 20 seconds
on the clock
so the 96 can't be dislodged that's the
really good news so Brooke ACB I'm just
gonna say she can choose between Brooke
c1 or rogue g1 she went with the
Seabrooke first which I think makes
sense but this should be straightforward
inch whoa why would she take on b7 and
go to the rook ending
well there's some Brooke F a check to go
to f3 so she took off this bishop so
that rook can infiltrate but now all of
a sudden again black is looking to give
these cam chances yeah it feels like the
rook may come to f3 anyway now if the
Brookes double on the F file and that
it's just surprising to me that we would
so quickly part with such a beast on d6
I think we're gonna get separated pawns
here some work c6 to go after the e pawn
black II know Brooke f3 check take the H
pawn boy something tells me that black
has a lot a lot more drawing chances now
than he would have before and maybe
black isn't even any and even really
worse anymore despite being down upon
here because of this threat of rook up 3
being so strong ok she stops it rook g3
now she can swing back to the a file
where she hits both a7 and then maybe
goes to a6 to hit a six it's okay I
guess white is still wait why it's not
even up upon what am I talking about
no well I was I was silently sitting
here because I was trying to do a quick
count of the material I don't know what
you were thinking about always challenge
me I I was under this impression that
when when she won the c5 pawn that it
was an extra pawn but of course it's not
in fact black is totally fine here he
five is a much easier pawn to target
than anything else so ya know the King
on before it looks good but it also
can't it's gonna come victim to this
rook attacks very quick then the e5 pawn
now looks like it's falling yup and this
looks like Hikaru's game so let's say
that you don't want to go King takes e5
because you hang the Jeep on so rook g7
makes perfect sense I thought rook d7 it
was an alternative to go to d5 would
check but I like this rip on the cheap
on you might as well get it there played
g4 play rook f3 and just keep pushing
that cheap on home
[Music]
so yeah the advantage is only increasing
here for black so another one that
slipped away here free phone
shoutout to our to our two biggest
supporters of the twitch TV chess
channel chess bay 94 and kitty-kitty
thank you for all the gifted subs over
there I see you so let's see is there
any chance here for white to hold an g3
now just keep pushing that Jeep on
mentioning it and it's good technique by
her car because on e5 could have been
captured at any moment instead he's
leaving that there he said I'll pick
that up when I want and now the threat
of course is g2 if I like rook f1 so
move like king b5 to get the King out of
the way of the rook so G she went rogue
d6 similar premise that of g2 I now
working d2 in order to keep that Jeep on
you Brooke on f3 to g3 which means that
you can't actually really make progress
with your ropes
so he'll be the first time scram but
we've seen though in this match we've
seen Yvonne really under time pressure
but this this could be one of our first
mutual time pressure moments coming up
here yep
and so Roxy three so now King d5 okay
you're invited deep pore to keep the
pond protected but she'll go back to c5
what this is not a drawn position I'm
sufficient there's no way Nakamura will
agree to a draw here I'd be shocked
right I mean certainly black has to be
the only one who can win still with this
pond being so much farther advanced
perhaps Brooke I was gonna say Brooke c2
or Brooke b3 keep the pressure on the
Queen side over here
so Casey okay I thought king c4 first
but Brooke g1 you must you cannot relax
here with the castle copy f3 where it's
oh I thought it would go to f3 where was
shielded but now what's going on here I
can't tell work a paycheck no it doesn't
work
but there may have been rook evading the
rook takes g3 Robert oh I think there
might have been
oh but then Brooke see to check was in
the air what's going on here who's
cleaning first are the e7 pawn just
hangs
not good okay but he uh he can't defend
it oh why give check judges are not
gonna check sir no bueno she's living on
the increment literally one second three
seconds now but she may have good
drawing chances at this point even if
she if she wins the a pawn
she may be in position where she can
even give up her rook at some point and
still
able to draw right but she's getting it
flagged I think I just don't trust her
mouse skills here especially with this
black King and crouching over here
you can never take on a sixes rook f1
comes immediately so you have to yeah
tickle long enough though to back the
king up maybe she should have been able
okay yeah she's really playing very well
here I'm super impressed with her with
her time scrambling skills right now
given uh-oh given that we haven't seen
that yet but it does eventually catch up
with her trying to defend this position
with really only time on the increment
so hey Caro does finally get it that was
crazy that was a tough game yeah that
was not not just super super easier
straight forward well defended there for
a long time by Yvonne I mean you saw
these checks no time could even keep up
really but it looked like if I was
defending extremely well but of course a
Caro was of a past bond and that's seem
to just be enough for him to pull
through for victory edog our resident
keep track of all potential adoptions
counter we appreciate that the car won
two out of ten again I've said I don't
think it's happening this time so but
anyway thank you all
nearly 3800 of you that are here we
still have more than half the match to
go for those who who maybe just got here
even though the score is currently
greatly favoring the top seed as was
sort of expected some super interesting
and instructive moments and a few of the
games we've had sorry for the Yoda speak
there sometimes you go Yoda by accident
you know I approve honestly you know six
minutes we will have our first quick
break and then we move to the faster
time controls so don't go anywhere
everybody so seven to one right now I
mean if on had some very good chances
and plenty of these games here but only
one point to show for it
yep it carved down about eight rating
points since when we started he's losing
a ton of rating for every draw and well
the matches going his way
in terms of results but you know I don't
know he's playing this sort of risky
chess yep
well now with the white pieces this is
the opposite of risky chess position
looks excellent here he has more space
he has control over the long diagonal
you can play simple move so he went at
four first that looks very good you'll
play Bishop f3 yep plays Bishop f3 you
can't go c6 is black because you're d6
pawn immediately becomes extremely weak
and you're gonna lose it if you take on
d5 now with the bishop up lacy takes d5
and you have a backward C pawn because
if I take with the bishop on d5 which
also looks good
then I think black can just play against
this Bishop on the like squares by
taking the C pawn now as mentioned rook
can bring the rook to c1 keep
pressurizing the c7 square and hope that
you'll outlast blacks defenses
well said partner like were you did you
black out during that that was awesome
oh yeah I just I see this backward pawn
it can never be pushed because the fish
won't have three covers the squares yep
and I think can I go G fort well I can
go g4 now there it is that's a very nice
move again well time because the knight
is pinned to the king yeah I was wrong
it's not always a rook that pins so I
haven't I think the only thing that
potentially keeps black a lot is let's
say go pawn takes g4 you take with the
bishop looks like I'm losing c7 but I
can go c5 an in-between move and now
when you take on c6 I take back with my
rook because your bishop is no longer an
f3 preventing my room from doing so I
think she's going for this I don't see
any other yep there's c5 really nice
tactical shot yeah hitting the Queen on
d4 hey karo with the WTF eyebrows there
you go but no it was one of those things
where what is it necessity breeds genius
right well here when you're in a spot
where the only option furry fun was to
come up with this idea of taking and
playing c5 she was able to find the the
very nice window
yeah I have no idea I mean I don't have
an engine up but I think that white
should still be quite a bit better
because the bishop is very strong but at
the same time the King is open know that
you played g-force it moves like queenie
e6 to h3 come to mind to work even
playing d5 at some point i don't want to
do that quite yet but at some point play
d5 because if you take AG over d7 to
ping your bishop so queen e6 played and
I really like that move just going over
to the h3 square and so now my Caro
prepares to defend it but now now I like
your now I like your d5 move there I
think rookie 7 makes sense as well to
hit III but d5 makes sense even it even
made sense when it was upon sacrifice as
you said but if you did it it would have
made the e-pawn backward on e3 and
actually opened up the e4 square for the
knight so maybe she should have played
d5 instead of rookie 7 so King g8
yeah no I thought if I was an option
you're right before rookie 75 would look
really good and here so the Queen wants
go to h3 but I am giving up and then f6
but I think I can get away with this a
Queen h3 you take on f6 if I take on
that 3 so we're just attack each other's
rooks and both Kings are very unsafe or
well that's unsafe there's not many
piece of tacking but both Kings are very
open so it looks like that they're good
very good drawing chances yeah and this
would be a draw that we would not be be
too critical of ephone for for taking if
she decided to to go for that she's down
more than a minute on the clock not the
worst time pressure or time difference
she's been in but still you start to
look at that in and and worried about
the direction of the game for black you
know any time I see her start her clock
ticking oh no cumec the ji said oh I
guess it's not so bad but give it no
time I look strong
yeah the fact to you when King g8 and
then back to g7 does not exactly
lead me to believe they are confident in
your position I mean the last two moves
e4 King g8 rookie to King g7 sometimes
important to be able to meet your
mistakes and actually that is a sign of
a very strong player is if you realize
the plan you're going for does not work
out to come have to have the courage to
change your mind mid move to say you
know I I can admit when I do something
wrong yeah I think that's it's an
honesty is courageous because it's we're
so likely to just keep on going to fail
to consider that while admitting you're
wrong is nothing in the world so just
just food for thought no I agree and now
it may pay off because one of the
reasons she didn't like her King on g8
everybody was cuz in those cases the
bishop on this diagonal perhaps pinning
the Queen on e6 and different lines was
was really a problem but it's not a
problem anymore so she can unpin the
knight on e5 material remains equal and
I think as you said Robert she made the
right call that the king was much worse
on the light squares that it was
originally on g7 though she still should
have played my d5 of yeah I agree I
agree and you know now we've gone to a
position where white if the Queen's get
traded White's trying to make use of
this outside past pawn on the Queen side
regulate a4 b4 b5 and use the fact that
Bhishma and g2 is so powerful but in the
current position black has firm control
over the Kings side the King on g7
actually looks quite safe you can can
you play rook d7 here does that work and
this is one of those positions where I
know she hasn't gotten a win yet and
maybe I've jinxed her once or twice but
I think who's coming but this is one
that I I wonder if it could turn quickly
because when you have this potentially
open King here for white and we know how
dangerous the Queen and Knight can be
together as attackers if she found some
way to get the Queen and Knight
coordinated over here on the King side
Robert it would be very dangerous for
Hikaru yeah I like it I like h5 because
maybe maybe h4 comes in maybe she yet
Queen g5 again h4 h3 may be coming note
that she don't write get back King out
of the way maybe to start with there it
is note that after Queen g5 a move like
Queen d2 offering Queen trade was not
possible because of 19 Knight of 3 for
King I think a court just saw that and
decided to move to safety but here comes
the night i i know i've jinxed it before
but i somehow i feel like this is gonna
be one of the ones that turns the
opposite way and here caro-kann is
shaking his head right now
yeah I love blacks position and I kept
trying to make moves like rook d7 or c7
work
as the white king is in the back rent
but then he looked so yeah it might have
been options there now just nice takes
before as a free pawn she took it and
well black is clear in the driver's seat
yeah it's not as ideal as a mating yet
maybe as far as the Queen a knight
working together and so I think that's
why Hikaru is kind of kind of like well
you know this this made me not as bad as
it could have been but but certainly
Yvonne should not lose this yeah well we
have said that before so unfortunately
just because it looks like she shouldn't
lose doesn't mean that she won't and you
know nobody should take that as a sign
of her being that yeah that's not
necessarily a my hair it's more of a
testament to what hey Cara Nakamura is
capable of in these settings so ok but
the pawn on h4 could be a nice target
right now she's got to be considering
whether she can just go gobble a5 right
and avoid a perpetual but Queen takes a
five the Queen comes into d7 okay we're
gonna find out it looks like a draws
Queen seven yeah she's she's trying for
it oh I like King f6
yeah I like it too be aggressive be ei
gg oh you can't go King at five I guess
there's Bishop h3 is that it yeah Bishop
h3 it'll turn the tables probably but
maybe you can there's runner King to e4
I would do it you're down so many points
that you might as well so they're
repeating back and forth this is the
last game of the five minute portion
with the one second increment reminder
you know it's a five minute portion with
the one second increment then a three
minute portion with a one second
increment and then a one minute portion
with a one second increment so we are
ending the longest time patrol and this
will only increase Hikaru's advantage
well okay three minutes
I think it's relatively similar but when
we get to the bullet will see a car just
go into full beast mode it'll turn into
the Hulk on camera for us which it seems
sort of dangerous to give him in like
that Red Bull but apparently they did it
you know so you should've seen a car a
Red Bull would not have been they would
have been like hey what do you think a
car needs more of I wouldn't have said
Red Bull but you know teachers um all
right well bishop comes to Eve
Morin as we said 'if on 'if on shouldn't
lose this but it doesn't mean that she
won't now she's under time pressure and
okay I gotta think Queen to be five
makes sense you guard d7 and you should
just be fine but I'm trying to figure
out I think both players are playing for
a win in a way in the game I think he
Fon is now concerned her King safety so
she's in running back and forth you know
she doesn't really have the option to
play for winters were playing not to
lose but ke7 here now bishop g6 and my
queen c6 check picking up that bishop on
g6 and the very least you enter an end
game where you're up queen and two pawns
is going in one pawn so this is a big
turning point actually because Queen III
here is probably met by Queen B five
they're all can spin the bishop and just
maneuver your King on the dark squares
so Queen e5 here makes a lot of sense to
me King d6 also give right I really like
King b6 and one of the funny things
about these types of Queen endings
everybody is at some point usually the
way to win you have to be willing to
bring your King into the fray and and
know that yes there will be a bunch of
checks maybe even ten or fifteen but if
there is safety probably at some point
for that black King over on the Queen
side protected by the queen of the night
and if you can find it then you could
get back to doing what you want to do
which is push your passport a g6 check
picks up a pawn king f6 and then we'll
probably see the draw finally yeah Queen
67 Bishop takes a shot okay now King g7
black can play for win Hikaru Amaro may
push this one past past the point of no
return if he's not careful because now
h4 and the bishop are under fire and for
the first time Hikaru might be under 10
seconds in the match and I'm not worried
about him flagging but I am worried
Queen h4 check take on Age 5 Queen g5
check and maybe throw that influenced
life first yeah I agree
okay it's just a draw King f1 Queen f6
check that you know it's a draw by Queen
65 Queen takes before and the King just
runs da once where this is a very simple
draw for me but could she have played
Queen D 1 or than Queen d3 I'm not so
sure that that was just an easy draw I
think we're gonna get that way but Queen
D 1 check and then Queen d3 Robert keeps
that White King off the potential to run
over and then you can just run your king
up nobody
to offer a trade of Queens because in
the endgame but are the king is within
the box yep there you go and just like
we're seeing now everybody when we say
the King is within the box that means
this when you look at this position if
you can draw a line from the queening
Square to where your king is and it's a
perfect box that is a quick way to know
that your king will catch their pawn in
case you didn't know that about Kingdom
pawn endings you're welcome
and in case you didn't know that the
speech chess championship rolls on
that's exactly we're gonna be doing for
the next 90 minutes we're gonna take our
first quick break right now she resigned
what it says she resigned she meant to
click draw I think oh my gosh she
resigned and she actually didn't know
it's okay take Oh take a break we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out I
don't think Accardo is gonna hold it
against yourself take a break and we'll
figure it out
she's looking at us on camera like wait
no Dani will figure it out either way
we're gonna take a quick break there I
don't even know that a car would mind
calling that what a draw but either way
I'm not going to take too much about the
scoreboard right now we'll be right back
with the three minute portion well
well there's a little bit of thought
about a little bit of discussion going
on right now about the situation with
the resignation but I'm not gonna worry
too much about it I believe the score
the score will stand based on that that
was the result and certainly this is an
online chess tournament where things
like Mouse lips and bad connections and
I guess sometimes accidental design
button can count but if we want to ask a
karo afterwards whether he agrees it was
a drug will do that and perhaps adjust
the score later on and in a news report
but Robert let's focus on what matters
which is we have the three minute
portion ahead of us
Yvonne will be back momentarily and I'm
gonna do what I normally do which is
asked you to be a coach and give her the
encouragement she needs to play faster
and trust her intuition more what would
you say yeah I would say you're getting
many good positions so you don't have to
really worry about the opening so much
it seems like her openings are well
prepared she's getting advantages of the
wide pieces she's doing a good job of
neutralizing with the black pieces yeah
the real issue is a critical moment
she's spending way too much time the
game just sticks out to me every time
it's a twin Knight takes d5 Bishop a3 we
had been talking about that decision 45
seconds before she finally made it and I
know that she's extremely strong player
and so she needs to trust herself a
little more and conserve time have you
unserved your time you won't get in a
bullet brawl with akaru which you are
pretty much certain to lose because of
how good he is so that's really where my
advice would leave her just continue
playing your good brand of chess the
results do not match the performance so
you your results should improve if you
improve your time management agreed 100%
and right now it looks like another game
is going between ray Robson and Yaakov n
but our next three minute game has not
quite begun yet Evon is not back so we
will be starting it as soon as soon as
she returns but I agree with you totally
and again I know it's easier said than
done when you're also playing a really
strong player to play faster but because
there are so many moves where the
moments where the move is obvious or
forced or required those extra few
seconds you take always end up coming
back
bite you when you do so unnecessarily so
not a bad idea to get you your coaching
shoes for those who don't know Grand
Master Robert Hess is the official coach
for the u.s. women's Olympian team quite
the honor and a Cara Nakamura actually
voted for Robert to be the coach of the
men's team although Robert didn't get
that job this year maybe next time
yeah the open teaming with Alec
Slenderman and how could you be
disappointed that was a great choice
yeah when they won the gold medal at the
last Olympia with London Munez coach so
clearly a good decision the application
is the same so I just figured that said
my name places I coach the women in 2016
and I'm very honored and appreciative
that they have faith in me to coach them
in the 2018 but to me yeah as well so
you're welcome for us putting you on the
on the spot there and getting you to
getting you to be more in your coaching
coaching mode so reminder everybody
thank you so much for all those who have
already donated and helped bring the the
price point up even higher the starting
prize fund is of course what you see the
price fun is now at a little bit higher
so always always appreciative of that
want to just thank everybody for all the
support and know that all those
donations go directly to the players all
right three-minute chess it's on well we
see that Yvonne very good position here
with the white pieces strong center was
a bishop on h8 that's entombed by the
own pawns but the good news is that you
put f5 at any moment the bad news is
that by playing f5 you give control over
some of those dark squares to to white I
would even consider the move g4 here for
white it looks very strange but I don't
want blacks play f5 clearly is the plan
so if I played g4 you're not gonna play
a5 yourself the bad news is you might
just like Bishop g7 trade off the
bishops then lose the to me use the f4
square against me and you know and the
aftermath fair trade so here's f5 coming
it should be three so I like blacks
position a lot now the problem is this
d4 pawn is gonna be forever be a target
black is threatening f4 at the right
moment yeah this is
going in Nakamura saver as this game
continues here yep
agreed a tough one
yeah it's just you it's hard even find a
move here because you want to play g3
for white to stop f4 then you see that
Bishop on b7 potentially opening up and
now just Queen c7 ignore that night
because the d4 pawn is still a problem
and if you play Knight f3 f4 actually
traps your Bishop on you three so this
is looking terrible for white now yeah
this is I don't know how white saves the
material here if you'll move your queen
away so Queens just your pawns not
pinned on d4 your queen and black place
c5 undermining the protection of the
knight on e5 yeah this is I think
already losing for white honesty well f4
yeah this is really tough ooh for a
second I thought maybe that tactic was
premature but yeah it seems pretty
straightforward so just okay it could
have played Queen d6 probably to pile up
pressure but I like this move the bishop
back to f8 put it on c5 there's
weaknesses on the Kings side there are a
lot of holes to exploit Bishop c5 I like
Queen d4 Queen d1 or something like that
could lead to a checkmating and now
Bishop a4 removing this night away and
so many good moves here okay Bishop g7
makes sense I was gonna say Queen b6 to
a3 just to make progress in the Queen
and there's Queen d6 this is a very
unfortunate position here for well and
also pretty unfortunate by the clock too
I wasn't even looking at the clock but
you're right 2 minute advantage ya know
that's the biggest oh and a blunder of
the Queen so time was was the biggest
factor now it is no longer the biggest
factor
so another win for a car and hmm it's
okay playing a normal little star would
be three but it turns into a bit of a
normal structure now and with yep
pollen c4 and y can play d4 and will
play d4 in the relatively near future is
to expand the center and so oftentimes
black ignores this and plays Bishop g7
because if you take on e5 and there's my
cue for stuff but by playing key force
or early you for white you say I'm gonna
go ahead and win this pawn and now
Bishop f5 for black will come to protect
the pawn on e4 but then perhaps I can
always kick that Bishop away it's and
out wait we're at 95 here yet 95
tactically defends that pawn because 95
if you take on e4 I'll take you you take
it back on e4 and then I'll move my
knight away perhaps to f3 with check and
take the dark square Bishop off the
board and I'll show that line on the
board for everyone watching and curious
who did it's happening it's exactly
what's gonna happen here and ok it's
it's still a poem for white despite the
dark square bishop falling but my
biggest worry about it is that oh she
doesn't go for it although maybe she
will next cuz now you could still play
Knight f3 oh no you couldn't not anymore
my player so ever the f5 here f5 kicking
the knight and then play f4 just keep
pushing that bond on the board mm-hmm
that would be quite a nice checkmate if
something like f 5f 4 happened and it's
some sort of discovery against the King
on e1 but likely not strange though
right for her to lose this pawn and then
not go for something aggressively you
know as compensation seems weird the way
she approached this right I mean not
playing for Knight of 3 check
I guess you know still does have time
based on the fact that her car does have
to complete his development and get the
King out right yes oh um f5 here comes
f4 yeah this is actually still pretty
hard for a Carl yes he's underdeveloped
and that's the thing that is hard for
many players to understand is that even
when you win upon if you your pieces
can't get out yeah compensation as a
concept is difficult to understand and
here for example black can even play
rook 88 and if you take on g4 I go take
with my knight on g4 and all of my
pieces are aiming at your king so that's
a possibility here yeah that might be a
really fun line actually if this
something like this were to occur on the
board and black were to get a massive
attack she's taking her time to think
about it decides not to but I do believe
at some point at some point you're gonna
have to be aggressive on the e-file
before white completes development and
yeah I mean if white plays Bishop e2
here which is the idea is to get that
development now Queen g5 happens and g2
and all very nice this my before I like
it opens up the idea of Queen h4 check
along with the e-file because now g3 not
possible okay though unfortunately after
came to d1 or or King e2 actually
there's not an immediate follow-up for
black despite white losing the right to
cancel yeah g5 g4 I guess I just go
forward with an attack but you're right
it's not okay it's not immediately
devastating so Queen d7 white there well
I don't know why you'd move your queen
back
okay she's maneuvering her bishop what
does that do
she was Queen g7 perhaps but why did you
move the Queen from h4 when you could
win g5 g form right away right that's
just yeah go for the Atty makes no sense
to because now the time she lost with
the Queen doesn't punish white at all
for the time he lost with the king and
he's basically just Castle queenside and
up a healthy pawn actually the it's
pretty funny here that neither side
really got much to show for that Queen
h4 check positionally black is okay
despite being down the pond mainly
because this Knight is such such a
dominant square but again the more the
game goes on here the fact that she's
already under time pressure and that the
Kings side is gonna open you really
start to like you really start to like
white here yep and so also I'm instead
of c6 I wanted to play g4 for black
because I'm worried if white plays g4 at
some point
h4 was played now it's getting really
messy on the side of the board
yep and h4 now even you'll play h5 for
white like right now and just kick this
bishop off the diagonal and I could take
with the e pawn and once I say with the
e pawn on d5 my knight can come to e4
after that so h5 was just played and now
he takes d5 looks good well but also h6
and the threat of taking f4 in term is
opening up the G file
yeah I was gonna say I think he takes up
four first before recapturing on d5 yep
and now there's a target that's not a
great transition for Afon but at the
same time this King on d1 still is not
safe she's down upon she can go for work
a to f8 for example continue to put
pressure over there on the up different
than I was expecting
that's not at all the Brooke I was
expecting to go there but Network a to
c8 this King on d1 is not a great piece
yeah so she has to think about playing
g4 playing Bishop f6 all the stuff like
kind of okay maybe it's not so bad but
just feels backwards so f4 is coming for
now for is probably too dangerous right
before his just a target no but I agreed
that she seems to be going backwards but
interestingly enough despite that no
don't go be five-o now the night's gonna
come to c600 but she has some forcing
follow-up that was a bad idea
cast room yeah and that taking g3
wouldn't even be great because now
there's all kinds of darks were
potential for white to play a move like
Queen c3 at some point and made on XI
7th yeah this is tough yeah not the
route that we expected it to go so with
this open diagonal Queen comes the d4 at
any moment but not rook takes g5 is a
free pawn ok over this domination on the
diagonals is what this game is a 2 is
one of those desperate moves hoping yet
you don't forget or maybe hoping that
somebody's pre moved so Queen takes f7
doesn't work but that's the idea so now
he's gonna work next move we take 7
check take take 87 game over yeah I
thought perhaps even h7 was fine first
but this also works and with no time on
the clock another one bites the dust
well this has been super impressive so
far by Hikaru in addition to the fact
that we know Yvonne was the underdog and
you sort of expect a Carver to be the
stronger player I may end up being wrong
about my predicted no adoption at this
point so how many in a row is it right
now well given that the one that should
have been a draw I don't know that that
can really count as a win for Hikaru so
yeah yeah I think we're back I think
we're back to a zero setting in terms of
the adoption counter
well that's not so good but okay with
the white pieces she once again has a
good position here no you're right I
mean you gave great coaching advice and
that's why we know you're a good coach I
mean openings haven't been the problem
transitions to the middle games haven't
been the problem I don't even know that
tactics have been the problem it's all
come down to one thing which has been
time pressure and at this point it's
it's a really hard thing to adjust mid
mid match mid game but you have to force
yourself to do it so you know something
interesting when white when he fine just
like c3 I move 14 if it was a car with
the white pieces in a blitz game he
would have immediately played Bishop d4
and if you play rook d8 pinning the
bishop he would have sacrificed his
Queen for the dark squares right like
I'm immediately I think that's just a
very good practical decision in both
classical and blitz chess but we see
these kind of hesitation these you know
reluctance free fonts really mix things
up in certain positions so I think she
missed an opportunity to play Bishop d4
right away and just take over the dark
square she still has a good position you
don't get me wrong but I do think that
was a missed opportunity particularly
from a blitz point of view agreed 100%
and the moves that follow right like 23
seconds on Knight g3 I think those are
moves you have to play faster so right
but why does white isn't a good position
here rookie one nice move the Queen
backs up you have these double pawns to
play for so Queen III hits a seven
perhaps now you maybe play a move like a
three-two take a pawn off of potential
being the potential being grabbed by the
bishop okay b3 also does it and maybe
even better because now c4 will kick the
bishop out of that really strong center
square yeah and the position just looks
very beautiful for for white so if I'm
black here I think well drop had rook e8
and give up the two rooks for the Queen
saying that well that gives me better
chances especially with a bishop against
Knight dynamic I could play h5 to h4 so
I would certainly consider playing a
move like
but if I'm white and I you know you put
the onus on Yvonne to say well am I
gonna accept that yeah dynamic here we
see I'd go Queen c5 here just say you
know my position is dominant the endgame
is great for me but if I take on the 8th
now all of a sudden as I was mentioning
it's a completely different type of game
right yes and we've always said that in
in fast time controls the Queen just
whether she should or not objectively or
or would in a classical game the Queen
tends to be such a better piece and
right as we say that Yvonne's gonna go
for which ok that's not the wrong chess
decision right I think she can play rook
III she plays rook c1 that's fine too
white is is much better here and this is
the right classical decision but I agree
with you that's Queen c5 keeping the
dynamic was probably the the easier
practical decision so isn't Bishop takes
g2 just a move here okay Queen c6 first
but I thought Bishop takes g2 is just
free pawn same with the same exact idea
so this is already again it's it's
really tough because in a classical game
you'd have this opportunity to really
sit relax take a breath and think about
how this would go change the dynamic in
a blitz game you don't have that same
opportunity to think and so you're in
this position where you say the torque
shouldn't be better than a queen but now
we see the bishop was just landing on g2
to win a pawn and I know she aims and
she immediately blah I wanted to play
rook e3 instead of rook c1 precisely
because I'm like playing the Karpov
chess right I just want all my pieces
defended no tactics and not playing that
way ends up just blundering into a into
a position where now her king is gonna
be open so yeah not if I was a good
decision considering what's going on
here take on g2 oh you can't like King
h2 was queen of forest annoying check so
rook g3 here black with like Queen e2
and come for the a pawn the good news is
that the because the black pawn
structure is so compromised I mean look
at that all these every pawn is I say
this is a symmetrical is a mirror image
for black but they the H and a then
heavens it's just a gross
pawn structure but because it's like
that it makes it harder for black to win
because even if you take the a pawn off
the board
you're not creating a passed pawn so
easily well now f3 just looks very good
for black you're just making an attack
so yeah he plays Queen e2 which I wonder
if he's just gonna repeat because
probably Brooke 3 to d2 no she plays her
quantity 2 which is also fine Queen e1
kimchi too but why didn't black ever
leave it looked like after his leading
to mate for black before now now white
can play rook f3 because you can't
actually attack my room from the square
oh yeah this is actually getting a
little dangerous for black if my rook
can find a way to hit f4 to hit exactly
hit f4 but at the same time I mean I
came to take it because these end games
are still bad for white that's how tough
this position can be
well it's interesting to just some of
these blitz strategy blitz observations
that we've made and are making about you
know decisions like to give up the clean
for the two rooks though practical and
sort of abstract they are usually things
that you have a better feel for when you
played a lot of online blitz and bullet
right and so even for you I mean you're
not hey Karim Nakamura in terms of the
amount of Blitzen bullet you played but
you know you play more online I think
than Yvonne does and I think that that's
why you would have better intuition and
to trust your judgement in those
situations I expect her to lose this
game mainly because of time and the and
the practical nature of the Queen being
so difficult to deal with in fast time
controls yeah but she's spending she's
burning clock in critical moments here
and kinghorn now now King before oh my
gosh that would have been sweet King me
for it and the the evaluation bar saw it
the black was winning but a Caro didn't
yeah I guess I don't have an evaluation
bar but when the King starts moving in
the threatens the sacrum where's the
Queen for the rook waves 5 here same
idea o Queen 8 or queen a5 I'm gonna be
sacking on f3 now Keaney - oh no now
don't worry
no but f3 I just go rook III check and
then the problem is then you still gonna
take a 3 right but I just go key e1 your
queen you can't can't stay in that
configuration forever ok so here I hmm
g8 what is that but even with the missed
opportunity it still is just super tough
here
pretty fun to hold she's gonna do her
best to sort of pre-move the situation
each it was a very good move never
updated me okay now she seems to have
defended her way out of it but it but
she's she's losing some time that was a
sneaky move yeah rookie three don't do
it again though cuz then clean yeah yeah
yeah wait what's what's going on here at
some point why team cuz they're playing
work d8 but like it's tough to sit
forever and do nothing uni for again
Kiefer wins it wins in the spot there it
is oh and their mitten cuz white kit is
running out of moves you can't keep your
Brooks defendant forever and she yes she
lost sometimes well again I mean that
the opportunities were missed but
eventually hit karo did what we've seen
him do right use the time use a big
advantage on the clock to push a
position that even objectively that
final position is probably a draw right
it's just the fact that she doesn't have
any time on the clock yeah I mean once
the King got to e4 she's in trouble but
earlier she was doing well to defend it
off and the thing is Dan is we keep
talking about time if you had more time
you can say well as white with the two
rooks could I play rook da start coming
after blacks pawns may my rook on f3
can't be attacked another time because I
was of rook e8 check but she had no time
to consider that so she's shuffling her
pieces back and forth yep and then
Hikaru would just shows his prowess both
strategically and in terms of quick
chess so his reflexes are an intuition
or a great combination he's just you
know unintentionally showing off his mic
yep well then plus I saw a comic a car
was a dirty flag dirty flags happen a
lot and I'm not saying a carro is not a
dirty flagger but in these situations
with increment it's not exactly the case
you know III think that some would argue
that's one of the reasons why he karo
hasn't been able to beat Magnus Carlsen
in this format is because of the
increment and you know those that just a
little bit of extra time even if it is
only one second makes the chest matter
instrumentally more right you just don't
get those crazy all-out true leader ii
flagging somebody positions so III don't
feel like it's a cargo flag here I feel
like it's it's bad time management but
based on the fact that you know you're
you're you know you were in a better
position really when
position perhaps earlier even before you
played queen takes for the two rooks but
under time pressure it's hard to keep
playing moves at the level you need to
so yep in a position like this Danny
actually is kind of in the same vein is
the black pieces with no clear plan of
how to make progress yet I black to play
a four on the safe yep and it's one of
those moves I would play both over the
board and in blitz the reason why a four
was so good for black is it gives you a
clear plan doesn't chisel open the
queenside hammer through on the be three
square and then maybe double your rooks
there now with the black pieces I'm just
like look at my position if white just
goes Knight to e5 you know Queen to e5
here at offer exchange of Queens but
whatever Knight to e5 I I just don't
like blacks position you're stuck with a
backwards e pawn you haven't played a
four yet so maybe I can avoid it all
together
well now a for just play a four I mean
that's really my advice right now is
just play a four I guess the drawback is
Queen a3 and then I take over the a file
but you need something to do as black or
she does it
yeah a four makes sense the big issue
though as you said Hikaru is not gonna
do anything with those pawns and though
once the smoke clears black has a whole
lot of positional weaknesses to deal
with east six the CC pawns so how would
you get counter play not really maybe
you have to play rook a8 and try to
fight for the a file
no there's nothing there's nothing on
the F far worse I was gonna say she
should have cuz here comes row k-6 and
the c64 is oh we don't take that pawn
quite yet look at the King on g2 oh yeah
yeah that would be it would be a pretty
fun little tactic here everybody up I
can get black gets d4 attacking the
Queen and pinning the rook to the king
that would be that would be a big
problem so you're Carlos sees it plays
Queen e1 now the question is are you
trying to trade b3 for c6 you love to
trade one of your weakest pawns for a
more healthy pawn on b3 but the problem
is the c6 pawn is sort of just a gateway
drug to the rest of the week pawns for
black sea Fryman e6 so now that's maybe
I would have played Bishop e8 there
instead but I think acara will take on
c6 and a media
we get more access to these other weak
bones if I'm black on intuition I go
Queen takes d3 and just say your king is
exposed in the light squares like
another person and I think I think if
you do that and immediately fall in ip8
with even a move like 94 threatening
rook up to who knows right you mix it up
and put a ton of pressure on your
opponent yep and so now with this knight
on e5 it's funny Danny when we look at
an nh-2 we actually say that's a very
strong piece but most people look at
that night or when people who are not as
experienced say this night and she's not
doing anything
it covers g4 it covers f3 it's not going
to be under attack of crazy tactics
happen so here just rook e1 right can we
just switch gears to the Queen side and
just the over K 737 and check me on the
Seven Network B won't play Queen on a1
doing a great job of aligning the rook
to go forward on the a file and also
protecting the knight on e5 rook a 7 was
a good looking moved there so now Queen
de8 at least you're staying in the game
wait I know I thought okay I thought D
takes T for his problems in the light
squares of rooks e7 just me up doubled
rooks on the seventh rank feels bad man
Queen d5 f free wait is there a check
yes rook the rook the knight is pinned
from f6 I was like where's the checkmate
h7 is covered but once I take on g7 I go
rook h7 check it's a force mate because
Knight g6 double check in fact here we
go we're gonna see it everybody brooke
takes moves rook rook h7 and then knight
g6 double check and mate on h 8 or 9 f7
double check and mate on h6 that might
even be prettier mmm you dirty girl I'll
show everybody yours up too late
can't show game switch but yeah that was
a that was a nice finish by her car yeah
just critical moments right with these
things where I think about I I'm just so
prone to sacrifice in exchange I love
doing it but you know it's difficult if
you're not you custom having that kind
of style of play where you just give up
the exchange and go on the initiative
that is a car style of play I mentioned
in consecutive games where there's that
Bishop D for sacrificing the Queen for
the dark square
and in that game it's gone Queen 63 and
giving up material and I know I'm fully
aware that in my position it's so much
easier to say this because I'm not
playing and I know when I play a car he
often just wipes me off the board so
it's eat yes do as I say not as I do
come a thing but I also know based on a
Cara's game that he likes to mix up the
action so he's not afraid to make these
complicated even if objectively it might
not be the best move chess wise
practically speaking he's so fast that
he's in a calculator tactics more
quickly than I am a new fan will so yeah
things have really been going hit Cara's
way even when he fawns getting good
position after getting after a good
position and here I look at the pawns on
f3 no no all right after h3 and g3 III
I'm like well at some point but some
triple f4 and just break open the King
side and we see this bishop on g2 I
talked about this in a recent game or
maybe not that reason at this point but
what ideally happens if white goes efore
which didn't just happen but if I had
quit before you play against this lousy
LightSquared Bishop and now there's an
attack brewing because if you take on f4
of course I can always take with my name
enough for now
white did a great decision here he
founded a great move 94 saying you know
what my opponent g3 is is protected but
that's not even the important part the
important thing is I'm counter attacking
you yeah well I didn't like that capture
that's not what I would have done
because now you're just handing over the
dark squares the Queen can go to DA to
h4 the pawn on g3 coach has been left
there for the time being I don't care if
I lose that I was gonna suggest that she
does she should have done what she's
doing now before taking on a four played
King h1 preparing the opportunity that
the G 1 square is used by a rook
especially against the King on the open
G foil with the Queen on a1 but now now
she's looking to kind of bail out and
black will be much better in the endgame
because of the dark square Knights right
yeah no you're right
she should have maintained that tension
there she's playing a little faster this
game a little bigger and now Queens you
know Queens your five minutes of work
right because black can trade and then
trade on g2 and win it with a piece you
know that's unfortunate
so now can black and Akari just play
rook okay I think I've worked out five
then rub g8 behind it but ninety-three
does the same thing I want you never up
chages wins because g2 Zhang rook g8
dares plate yeah that's that's a true
Queen Street the Queen's trap you're
losing a piece even if the Queen what
weren't true I was wondering if we were
gonna see it even though I think she's
just gonna get completely killed I'm
always excited to see a queen sac yeah
but the problem is the Knights are still
on the board if you could trade the
Knights off you'd have much greater
chances to draw yeah but the problem is
it's not enough for is just wreaking
havoc in the position they each three
pawn is a week at any time I'm
dislodging your Bishop from g2 and your
knight on h4 can become a hanging piece
so if you just could knock those nights
off the board I think what chance of
drawing go up tremendously please pretty
rook on f3 and placing a four so that's
what she's aiming for she's doing a good
job here of trying to hold the balance
but if you do take on g2 then you as
white you can just take backup put your
9 g3 rook on f2 and shelter yourself so
that's that's the real issue for black
and trying to convert this is if you
trade the minor pieces too soon you're
not gonna have good winning chances but
the Queen is a queen right the queen is
a queen and these positions are much
much easier to play when you have the
Queen so okay how do you prod to get
weaknesses that the Queen can can win
with that that'll be the next question
but I think a for at some point well
this is one obviously the beasts so
straight up she plundered the night I
was I was not I wasn't looking at the
Kings side I swear I was looking over
the Queen side I'm considering moves
like a four I want to undermine the c4
pawn to be weak and all the sudden I
look back to the Kings side and pieces
cut lol totally weak I say lol I was
looking for the same kind of stuff
because well you're trying to win the
game and if you don't expect your pawns
blender so it's good to think about the
other side of the board creating a
second weakness yep and here you Fon is
now shared a pawn on that five and other
games you've seen this Pawnee for
without the
five and it's good to add that pawn
there because it cements your pawns on
e4 and you could play F for yourself in
the near future so now in Knight takes H
five should be played but again I said
when I say I had car was sacrificing
material for the initially I was happy
so Knight h5 work age five take Queen H
ride
here we go oh he takes c6 first but then
he'll take H five I expect there it is
but this is good for black Queen h4
trades the Queen's right welcome back to
e2 but yeah but no I agree I think that
despite the dynamic energy that Hikaru
brings with like you said being willing
to sacrifice the exchange this should
just be good free fun we're yet to see
you fawn get her first win so along with
pretty much anybody watching the show
that has a heart we're rooting for e Fon
to get a win let's hope that that
happens here yep and let's have it
without chances I would say that the
overall quality of chess hasn't been
much better for Hikaru over e fawn but
the main thing has just been the time
management with it so which is porta
chess as part of the game that's it's
certainly part of the speech Chess
Championship okay this is not gonna go
her way that was why not castle to
protect f5 because she's weird at work
h1 in like an attack on her King but
this is MELAS you can't castle now
actually but White's getting back these
pawns g4 is hanging d6 is weak I would
play I would play castle and just hope
that you're surviving I don't really
know what else you can do but Castle
Nathan Knight g5 yeah that g5 actually
looks even more irritating than the rook
on h1 would have been in the other line
if you a knight g5 will take on c3 I
guess and then play rook takes up 2 I
protect h7 this way I'm so scared to do
it you can also you can also take on c3
and play rook f5 oh that's kind of
annoying too that might actually be much
oh she doesn't but what was taking on c3
and rook l5 was that almost winning the
night it seemed
well this looks bad for I don't like
blacks position right now on the
analysis board looking at Bishop takes
c3 and then rook f5 is maybe maybe an
opportunity she had yep okay definitely
looked interesting
this still is interesting but now White
has a pawn and a light square bishop for
a rook and the rooks are not doing
anything here d6 is hanging rook g1 will
threaten the g6 night and that would win
the Queen so I don't even see a good
move for black here because Richie wants
to powerful threat so now virtue one
still works because if you take my rook
I hope we need seven checkmate it's a
rookie one just Oh
virtually midnight six f5 yeah Oh snow
that's one sec how many of these do we
do we need before we feel complete yeah
actually I really like what she just did
considering how awful I thought her
position was gonna be this Queen
sacrifice at least keeps her in the game
right and her King is weak so we'll
always like Queens when your enemy King
is weak right we want to keep that green
on the board so b4 played that makes
sense trying to go b5 I guess and King
b3 is an option just extending space in
the Queen side h5
yeah third Queen second four games so
now I can't go after your f2 pawn now
this is cars playing this part very well
very accurate so Bishop c3 bishops c3
rook takes F to check King moves reflect
to have seven but you probably beat me
with your to Pat your two pawns in the
Queen side it's one one over there and
I'll lose my H pawn as well wait isn't
that just a free pawn Knight takes
Knight takes d5 bishop of beats you and
rook takes F to check how does that pan
out
complicated but the h4 pun also falls
that's why I would you know want to take
on d5 because I'm thinking I win the D
pawn and I'll win the a chiffon soon
after but at the same time I don't
really want to give the f2 pawn so ya
know there's real problems because of I
don't know but Ritchie 5h4 couldn't have
been taken maybe it could have but a car
doesn't go for it yeah there's some
Brooke g2 stuff so she's trying maybe
she's trying to get after this f2 pawn
the car doing is very best to keep it
but now for blackboard if you look at
five back you can't go f4 for white
because I think I have before I was
gonna say I think d4 is a candidate move
here as well she takes to get f2 though
okay so now night at 595 get active okay
now she's trying it she's turning this
on rook e1 just go for it
rook g1 bring the rook around mating
that time okay King up someone's also a
good move but you just going over t1 you
have to find ripped u1 and you got to
find it quickly that's you know what's
Chronicle yes you found it but you're
doing this Kate the Queen is actually
completely frozen on this square no
moves no way out yeah and she can't uh
sorry a car cannot stop her from check
check check check check check check at
the very least perpetual right after b7
she can check and the king can never run
to the beef oil without eventually the
skewer and winning the pond so right and
the king cannot run too far as well
because runs I put a v1 check and he
runs the F I'll meet you in brocade to
mate so I think they were already in
rupee one rupee one check repetition so
go rook c1 and I think he'll know he
does over b1 isn't black better now 26
is completely winning rook c2 is mate oh
no I didn't I think kini 6 was made king
you like to keep up rook check would
have been made oh my gosh look at this
everybody on the analysis board King e6
there was no checks
and there was no way to deal with rook
c2 it's gonna be a flag look at 2.6
seconds left
yet but this is a time I mean she still
shouldn't lose but no time look at that
nice move Queen hey by the way was
designed specifically to stop like a
king ei pre-move tricky Hikaru Wow shoot
me there with 0.2 seconds left point 2
seconds but now there's nice c6 coming
oh she may have point two again she's
gaining some time go
oh no she couldn't do it
what said she was really playing some
great defense there
she played phenomenal defense and active
defense she really should have won there
in the end again King e6 King e6 trapped
the king yeah I mean I the king is run
making a wild run up the Queen side and
once it gets to c5 it's trying to take
up on d5 so King e6 protects your knight
on f5 and sounds like he was really d5
so this is this is tough I you know I
was just thinking about it because in
the first match we saw Fabiano get
totally obliterated by Leveroni in'
right LaVon just was on fire and I think
I was felt a little worse than that one
because Bobby on paper at least wasn't
as big of an underdog as he showed
himself to be right in this match you
know hey Cara was such an overwhelming
favorite that it's almost expected which
is source sad to say but you know it
becomes part of par for the course and
in this position again we see white
having a nice position I would think
she's just waiting for Castle King sizes
she played g4 now you can just take on
b7 and then play moves like Queen e2 or
chief Margie for you well this is one
again where the principal moves where
you just gain space control the center
be as aggressive as possible is the way
you get an advantage against this kind
of very passive opening by black this is
how zyada zoria beat Hikaru in the US
Championship he plays something like
this got a very passive setup and V odd
just punishment oh boy this looks really
bad really bad luck because you can't
even play six through nine
six checks just go Queenie to Castle
queenside this is yeah this is this is
the game she needs to get not to say
there haven't been others but taking
unnecessary time here would really be a
tragedy h4 h5 and just do it without
thinking in denna you're gonna
appreciate this but Yaakov nor wits is
in the chat and he said I got next he
doesn't pay attention to anything
outside of his own world where he plays
Blitzen bullet all night so this is
pretty well publicized in this is pretty
well publicized like everybody knows
about it and you think 'if on an Hikaru
are just randomly jumping into play a
massive epic match on chess calm it's
just funny yeah and it's also funny
because Hikaru is not exactly the okay
Yaakov let's go it's hilarious yeah
but speaking of hilarious this King side
for black is hilariously bad because
that knight on f6 morning she did just
rush the h-bomb though and I still feel
like it's time to just it's time to go
for the attack I agree with you h4 h5
with no shame yeah h4 h5 looks really
good because there's nothing there's h4
there's nothing a car can do to stop it
what take on h6 and put your net on g5
yeah actually don't just take on a6 and
don't put your 9 g5 because the bishop
will be terrible in h6 so just go G
takes h6 Bishop h6 and I don't know
something
King b1 maybe just get a king alright
she starts the king bee one but I didn't
like that because I wanted to take away
do the opposite
give yourself another open file to work
with still looks really good so what how
does white make progress here rook d7 -
Ewan Bishop c1 first so Rick d7 now yep
there it is and oh if you go rook c8 no
nevermind I was a blunder I said Kyle
Queen takes c5 but after Queen takes d5
so many things are hanging Quinn man
that
three but also rook takes T seven and
then the Queen on c5 would be hanging in
there too
so ignore that blacks position is
getting better I think
now when you commit to the pawn on b3 my
bd5 happens and c3 is a weakness a very
weak square block hit by c4 pick Cara
can't just open up the position more
this is not good not good so yeah so b4
now made by black just like b4 Queen a6
/ k 7 let's see
so b4 by white what a move what a
concept
so if I take the 9 f3 is hanging so how
do I properly attack it I don't know but
I'm just so disappointed that the
kingside got locked up it's just like I
feel like a car was a Houdini just from
the perspective that he faun getting a
win there was an attack would have been
exactly what the doctor ordered now f4
is hanging why can't I just take it if
he went 90 except for I'll play don't
know maybe 94 and the nights under fire
okay that's a pawn there comes the other
night gets out and black will be the one
with a mating attack before this game is
over
yep I agree
ninety-two was an interesting shot there
but I guess well I like many to Allah
that was like 93 so I could have taken
d5 though first with the night itself
gotcha now 94 for white wait couldn't
wasn't there some night see through
checking between moves now oh yeah both
sides making blunders in this game this
game feels a little sloppy to me
but again just it's a it's just a sign
of the Intuit the intuition that is just
not there free font in this format just
because or at least not on the level of
a guy like a car or Nakamura right
because taking a lot of time and not
just playing the moves that you and I
were screaming for and and now she's uh
she's losing yet another game that she
had no business losing so sad but okay
she's a true professional Yvonne knows
that she's the underdog in this format
she doesn't agree to it because of
anything but she wants to get better and
you know she she knows she was playing
that the pairing that nobody including
the two-seat sergey karaoke no one wants
to play Hikaru that's a fact
I agree no absolutely nobody wants to
play car because well he's earned the
respect of everyone for a reason he's
just such a monster these time controls
and you know what Danny after 15 to 1
score I believe he's gained zero-rating
points in this match yeah I think you're
right yeah this is the right where he
started 29 92 giving up a couple drawers
that's mean tisk tisk for Hikaru yeah
what a slacker wonder taking off the hat
though leaning in and and Robert Hess is
my witness that in our pregame prep and
all the production time that I'm putting
in I asked to Caro and he said
specifically I'm not gonna get any
closer than this he was his full face
was showing and leading up apparently
Robert he was gonna get a little closer
than that
yeah you heard him say that right as my
witness and to be fair he didn't leave
to the bathroom or something so maybe
when he came back he forgot his
positioning
I don't know I don't know who doesn't
look like this you know this angle here
we just get it's a headache cuz
afterwards I always have to hear it from
the other chest calm teammates like
Danny why can't you capture the cameras
perfectly and I'm like Hikaru is not on
camera right now he's not anywhere to be
seen this is true it's not not your
fault I agree Danny normally moving on
sorry moving on just my perfect
production but Yvonne looks great
she says she's kept her position and her
speaking up her position or position
looks amazing right now for black yeah
it does what the Kings on f1 for white
loves I was gonna say it was that a Mel
slip actually no no no okay okay it was
a check on on move 15 so okay got it
so she's layer pieces backwards but I
thought Queen h4 made perfect sense like
you just put your queen in a more active
space you hit the d 4 squared another
time you sort of keep white a little bit
stuck now what if light just was Bishop
f3
yeah Bishop a three looks good you have
a trouble moving the b-pawn to develop
the bishop because c6 becomes an open
square and maybe he just suck goes back
and forth here so go Queen h4 now why is
this 997 well she wants to bring the
knight to f6 badly right to come into
the e4 square and I think that's what
she'll go for now g3 Knight f6
kingi 294 I mean III like this plan for
her actually because even now she
complained 94 yeah okay so that does
make it actually a lot of sense a queen
f4 was played net now she can maybe play
maybe something to g5 i was gonna say i
want to put something on g5 just not
sure what it is i'm also looking at
night takes f2 tactics that don't work
because d4 is very well defended but
yeah I'm putting the king in a in a pin
it just doesn't pan out so something to
g5 okay I know that's what I wanted
there we go let's go let's go with the
aggressive chess g5 if she trades if he
trades everything on e4 it's a
phenomenal endgame for black with the
bishop pair and immediate pressure on
the 9th so that's not really an option
it is an option because really backing
up the Queen was probably even worse but
this is just good rate for black yep so
Bishop d7 something like that looks good
it was played get the other we foil
quickly you know quickly without
thinking there you go I feel like we're
coaching right now well you know I
really don't want to coach her because
since I'm coaching the women's team
against her you're not kind of it puts
me in a tough spot but you're you know
you are right she is doing a better job
this game of playing quickly and so
after be forged by Bishop d6 it's one of
those positions where okay Fischer may
seven but should be six just play one
and she did now can I go after the d5 on
rookie five yeah why not whoa whoa why
why do we like the obstacle Bishop
ending that's gonna help White's drawing
chances that didn't make a lot of sense
well she's a Bishop f6 she'll go King
age seven and g6 so that Lisa's good
news but yeah I did not want that to
happen if I'm black here so what's a
card doing haha Bishop a4 to make sure
that you don't have counter play that's
a very nice move actually just from a a
discipline standpoint really also makes
it very hard for white to ever challenge
the C file because that see two squares
held so so okay black is still in in a
position where two results are what
she's playing for Yoda two results are
what she's playing for so she shouldn't
really be able to lose this
so our people are debating whether or
not I would GM in the twitch chat so
it's pretty funny oh yeah yeah like it's
Robert has to jam song called me and
them I was I don't think I've been in nm
since I was like 14 or something I was
you before yeah it's okay
I tell everybody about the last time I
taught you at a chess camp when you were
and I am you didn't teach me anything
Danny wait a sec Robert tell them the
truth you said you loved my lecture and
you actually learned something from it
isn't isn't white going up a pond now
something really I got it yeah something
went wrong but she still shouldn't lose
I'm going to say it again so let's see
is she gonna hold this Danny I'm not
sure and yes I did learn a lot from your
lecture what was your lecture on again
oh great
I know you remember the game I don't
remember the game I have no idea what
you talking I'm sorry moving on
she five and then made on aged six NHA
and it shouldn't happen go for it go for
it it Carl
I'm surprised a car wouldn't see that uh
I think he did actually and I think what
he did was even better because if you
did it in my move order she had Bishop
c6 trapping the rook so I think what he
played with rook f6 was much better
precisely because he's gonna get it Oh F
fives check only move or f6 whatever in
both papasan
um pissant is just winning looks good no
he wants more you know why cuz he wants
g6 in mate
second aachen not a bad idea at all
knock on wood have lost did I say that
she could lose this one I thought I said
that you did say that hey Danny everyone
wants to know what the lecture was about
okay I'm gonna tell you the what it was
about and you're gonna have to remember
the game okay I'll try it was a grünfeld
the exchange sec line no idea whatsoever
Robert no I'm being serious my memory
about things from 2006 or Never or
whatever you were not very good and
check me it's about to wait yeah okay
Brooke comes to that side also only two
seconds who played in the game I have no
idea you're so mad at me but I'm really
not trying to joke oh and I don't get
mad at you legitimately Hannah Q was it
Petrosian we're rich no it was about
high-level opening preparation and it
was about expanding and improving on
other novelties it was the sheer off to
Paul off game in the exchange snack line
the Grunfeld oh it did which game was
that I don't won the bishop ending oh my
gosh you are just you're you're hopeless
III don't know you're talking about so
I'm gonna go back to talking about these
games yep because let's do it
I know this conversation to go though
king of Kim Peter goes Danny breaking
out the dad tone Roberts right I really
have no idea what you're talking about
anyway back to this chest here speaking
of things I don't know what I'm talking
about what fun is just in a great
position here so he's hit cars
essentially what he wants to do is trade
the lights for bishops plane 94 and play
f5 all at once and castle or you might
also want to play h4 and you know sac
sac mate as Fisher would say ya know say
a decent strategy so if you're white you
want to play no you don't want to do
this because now Bishop g2 and h4 it
looks great I was gonna say a play age
for first yeah age for first maintain
the tension now trade it all at once
you're gonna check the King to e1 I
don't actually see the follow-up mate it
takes everything Queen h3 uh
oh you take with the Queen you're never
happy from then on out after King takes
a car we'll play Queen of five here
castlelong
okay that's also something that works
threatening look to you for but Queen
upcoming this is not good Danny
it's not good at all nope I just yeah
now I'm starting to really feel that
pain vicariously through her here
because I know what it's like to be on
the losing end of vicious Hikaru
Nakamura games and so at this point yeah
I'm just I'm feeling that pain hey it
looks like someone's donated yeah yeah
snake mayor is that Kevin Durant okay
Bishop f6 so isn't black just gonna
Castle queenside and play Brooke h8 Oh
Queen have two stops castling queenside
is queen to know it doesn't really stop
it doesn't but king d7 does a smart move
because the a7 pond was sneakily under
attack by the Queen enough too
so funny Jack Z says I didn't expect an
NBA reference in the chest reom well
they clearly don't know me if they
didn't think I'm gonna talk about
basketball well they also don't watch
many of our streams I feel like we're
we're walking sports reference on a
regular basis and you love baseball too
I hate baseball
yeah that's why I said that Robert I
know you always have to sometimes you
just accept the joke
that's it fury eights me because
baseball I really don't like but I could
talk about basketball all day so smash
Bob Squarepants as Nakamura looks like
Jim from the office what yeah okay I
don't get that one me neither
well I'm the Earl Boykins of chess I
love Earl Boykins
I used to have his jersey because he's a
5 foot 5 NBA player yeah yeah I loved
Earl Boykins he could drop like 12
points a game and he had a sweet block I
think I like 30-plus blocks in his
career anyway let's go back to the chess
here buddy yeah yeah this is getting me
distracted here but Earl Boykins
was a boss five minutes left in the
three minute portion before the the
bullet show begins
hikaru calmly calmly scooting in a lot
closer than he ever said he would so
let's see isn't it's just devastating
the a pump can't be stopped if you take
on a ch3 I take back and my a pawn
starts rolling so now just take on C no
yeah take on c3 Pat Queen a7 check and
then play a3 should be good enough and
that's what it cars gonna do
yeah this is just very straightforward
okay rook b8 same idea go a3 a2 and get
a Queen h4 gives a king some space for a
faun but after six there's no meaning
attack or anything enough that was even
look particularly close to one car wins
again by resignation another one bites
the dust yeah yeah we'll get some Queen
references going on pretty excited for
that they'll be coming up the same
pretty excited I got a lot of people
talking about basketball here you stay
folk
my bad you know the inner sports
quotient of me is just coming out to
play but in this particular game with
the white pieces a card doing his
typical setup
he starts with b3 and what he's done
here is he's made a pawn structure such
that black will have hanging pawns d5
and c5 pawns
once y place cd5 has just happened and
these pawns are very vulnerable to an
attack because they can't protect each
other Paulin always likes to be
protected for another pawn at the same
time they control many of the vital
squares in the center of the board so
defy for now is very well defended c5
similarly and at some point black if
white goes night a4 you'll be mat by
moves Knight e4 so Bishop a3 it again
putting pressure on let's see 5 square
if I'm black I move my rook say the e8
or d8 makes perfect sense and 9a for now
you play Knight e4 to protect your C
pawn and to gain some space and center
of the board and don't be shocked if
black has Knight takes F to threats up
her sleeve because that's why one of my
work on EA my d5 pawn I thought was
gonna be defended so I put them in them
before I actually threaten ideas and
sacrifice in the F 2 square and Queen a5
has been played so what's the idea
c5 defended if you go Bishop takes a 6
now after a six work eight I pin you and
white should probably play rook c2 I
want to say yeah but after rook see -
I'll play Bishop h6 and come for you
have to square so wait now Knight c3
just pick some material so
a blender by her car right 93 just hit C
two hits d1 yeah he must have most of
this cuz it doesn't exactly win material
though right cuz rook can go to d2 oh
yeah rookie - I was gonna play d4 at
some point so yeah it's just d4 there
yeah I think rook D to d4 comes anyway
and I think he fought oh he's giving up
the a pawn and she doesn't want it she
wants the bishop here instead
maybe d4 nil but Bishop takes c5 Bishop
c5 then you're not threatening my queen
because rook e1 might be some I'll take
an f3 first because your Bishop was
pinned to your work on the back rank oh
very nice it's the same idea if rook
takes c8 their rook takes back on c8
with c1 mating idea that would have been
very nice so blacks played d3 here right
just push that pawn so you took on c5
after Bishop takes e5
okay so points if I play but take take
d3 that's a far advanced passed pawn but
it's not working out so Queen d7 I yep
played it's a good move well with only a
minute left seems more than likely that
this will actually be our our last 3 min
again before moving on to bullet so uh
unfortunately your pep talk for ephod
wasn't she didn't hear it Robert but
she's uh she's doing her best and Wow
huge cheer there thank you from Jack Z
and thank you for the last donation to
that I forgot to mention bringing that
prize fund up just a little bit of extra
spending money for the next time Hikaru
goes to the Olympia we know he needs
that extra cash yeah
so here take on III have stay with the
pawn has happened so white is up upon
and it's an important Queen side bond
and you know everyone can see that for
Yvonne it's a tough day a tough morning
I should say cuz it's early in China
right now but I think we should give her
a special shout out because she is a
Rhodes Scholar and so she will be
studying in Oxford come the fall time so
not only is she one of the reasons we
actually did the match so quickly
originally the planned date for Hikaru
and Yvonne was later I can tell you that
but um her schedule is a is a very busy
one just like acardo's but for different
reasons
she'll be at Oxford while Hikaru was
playing the Sinquefield cup wrapping and
blitz and classical she'll be there for
the whole month of August yeah yeah so
feels like she's holding agreed I like
this chief for plan take e4 so what her
car's gonna try to do is play a five and
then go after the a six pawn a
threatened idea would be five try to
push that pawn through so we started
working eight so if I'm Yvonne I'd point
Bishop on D to Prohibition detour g1
which diagonal do I want Bishop on it's
important first question actually yeah I
think the most crucial thing will be
counter play against the White King but
including using your own F pawn before
Hikaru gets anything too devastating
against a6 right it's a Bishop F full
okay Bishop d6 was played yeah I think
no Danny wrong wrong corner pawn by the
way so yeah it off a from B pawn and
just trade the rooks off yep and of
course what Roberts pointing out
everybody is that this pawn here would
eventually be cleaning on a light square
which is the wrong color when compared
to the bishop very important to always
have foresight in these types of endings
it's not just because you don't want to
get that endgame but it helps your
calculations and all the earlier
positions to understand where you can
and cannot drive the position when
exchanges get offered all these things
so very educational point there Robert
so okay just their ghost there's that
pawn break no talking about it should be
six likely yep so play rook c6 to get
the rook behind the pawns and rook c6
allows the ready to go see three to a
three yep
and then the b-pawn can also start oh I
don't like the passive setup the good
news is the rook can't go to b8 without
fish 25 yeah so that might be the saving
grace in the position but Bishop c5
which wins the be pond okay this also
similarly you can't go Bishop c3 cuz
rook b8 so I got Bishop c5 would've just
pick up the pot without any problems I
don't know why why he didn't know it
seems like the king will get back in
time okay
now although if we're talking about
corners Robert she it is the right
corner for black to be able to draw the
opposite color corner of your own Bishop
is the corner you want to be in if
you're drawing king and rook versus King
and Bishop so makes her job much easier
should she ever need to give up her rook
for the pawn and the bishop on a7 it
should be an immediate draw yeah but now
she's losing King be 5 yep why is she
losing yet Bishop e7 still rook f7 the
Kings he pushed the back rank King e8 is
met by King e6 here here he comes
there's now roof h7 rook d7 game over
OMG it's painful it is painful it's the
weight it was supposed to be their last
three mini game and the game has been
aborted the players it's time for a
break before the bullet that was the
last 3 min a game the the match is tough
right now we're getting we're getting
some some subscriptions we appreciate
that as well as all the donations and
all that all the support all five
thousand-plus of you that are here don't
go anywhere we have blood ahead we'll
hit Caro be the first person I think
ever to reach 30 points in a speech
Chess Championship match I don't think
so but Yvonne and hey Cara will
continue with the last segment of bullet
in just a few moments so we'll be right
back
sometimes I don't want to go away from
the commercial Robert only because I'm
like enjoying I mean that's like the
waiting screen I like I just like off
camera just like all right we we are
going to be off very very quickly here
with the the bullet portion and a match
that is proving to be very very
difficult for the Challenger Yvonne
what's whose mic is on no idea what
might be yours might be my bike who
knows let's start bullet we go the last
half hour we I have final confirmation
that after discussing the situation with
a carro that the draw will stand
mainly because as he and I both agreed
off-camera that given that there was
really no legal way for her to lose the
position and was clearly a mouse-click
seemed like the right however what
should be noted is that it is in the
rules that mouse clicks and Mouse lips
stand for those who've been with us the
whole time and now only that happy
resigned confirmation is an option
hey karo actually has it on and he says
for that exact reason so to be fair if
you play a lot online you're kind of
aware of these things so I understood
that and I think we're making the right
call so for those of you who following
care have any idea what I'm talking
about it will be adjusted to a draw
however if this were a close match the
mouse the mouse click miss click of
resigned would have stood so and the
discussion moving on from that topic
Robert what can she do to win some
bullet games well I mean we keep sawed
off playing quickly but unfortunate that
says hakanaku more his best time segment
where he is just such a monster a bullet
chest she's a great position here she
should play just any really any move but
I thought she should play d5 herself
because this is AI blacks ideas to play
d5 and so here with the H file being
open white is up upon but clearly a car
is going for work d-day for dh8
ACH for potential sacrifices and so that
is why Yvonne took on d5 okay so now hmm
manifold is very strong here
I'm very frustratingly strong so go
Queen I'm trying to figure out a best
way to defend wait Knight takes c6 well
bye Brooke takes c6 that was a missed
opportunity okay so now I took on h4 and
well black is worse here because black
is hoping for some of that sort of
attack but with the rook on g2 the king
is very safe so I think he finds doing
great except for the clock situation
right now she's really struggling with
the time and now Cara has complete
domination over the light squares yep so
his disadvantage has definitely been
shrinking in Outlook f2g one is the idea
for white but this pawn on 8 sounds
actually really difficult to attack any
further with this rook I'm 86 now were
caged 3 e3 is falling this is now the
car is game from taking so rook takes c3
is a free pawn next is oboes it's a
night except for but hunger piece or her
cage turd back yeah that's that's good
can't take on g6 his work h2 his mate
and win by resignation 19 actually 18
and a half but will be will be adjusted
momentarily but yeah so he's uh he's a
monster
he's pretty good a bullet yeah this is
very impressive
just as just display in recent games
just with the ten zero score in the
three-minute segment and now his bullet
prowess I've got a full display it's
very very impressive so now with the
white pieces he's done he's opted for
this setup we're okay the King asked to
move for black but the can't see sevens
very very safe and so just take on c8
back so now 96 okay even ninety six
limbs ago fifty eight it's not actually
gonna do anything on that square so okay
94 now why kimochi for g5 to undermine
the protection the e5 pawn it's
something that black really has to keep
an eye on I would think about playing so
h6
995 happens and then I gonna he six is a
problem QC 8 looks like they moved to
play because that way you get out of
this 96 check
and so king c8 okay now make you see but
now 96 like anything like she could
maybe just play brook g8 I don't know if
she needs the bishop anymore
I guess she plays broke g8 anyway but
I'm not I really want to take the bishop
as much as I just want to say blacks
pieces can't move and so now after a
rookie Bishop takes you seven rotates
mate they're angels a piece here so the
knight is trapped and I don't see how
you get out of this night at five I just
go g4 yeah chief force coming now Knight
g7 only move Knight f8 got it of a what
a strong move especially in bullet then
the knight comes to h4 he's gonna work
it working through six he's so quick
like it's unbelievable how how quickly
he just finds these tactics one of the
questions will be over/under how many
games Hikaru finishes with more than 45
seconds it might be all of them yeah
this is uh this is upsetting you know
but honestly a gift you find folk folk
credit she's fighting she's playing her
best and well when you play car Nakamura
this is sort of what happened I was just
about to say we're gonna see a fancy
mate with b4 and then Knight c8 she
defends it but not enough it's still
made on c7 yep so I'm ready for her to
get a game because look at the rating
differential here on chest comes mr.
Burriss 30 goal in a single game makes
all of her carros +3000 rivals happy so
does it cars gaining zero rating points
for every win yeah I hope you know that
ya know it's yeah he's in the 800 point
plus difference range 707 700 600 is the
cutoff right got it
whoa and I see kitty kitty hiss hiss
gifted a sub that's 55 gift subs in this
channel yes kitty kitty hisses and chess
bay 94 are have been nothing short of
amazing along with snake mayor who's
been who's been rocking some gifts
appreciate everybody
use your emos proudly especially if it's
a gifted sub right shake what your mama
gave you the my apologies if there are
if there are some sound issues with my
microphone but we're gonna continue to
focus on the chest as what matters here
and for the girls use the emotes for the
girls
Tommy Shelby goes Hikaru is Manute Bol
yeah is hilarious okay he would be he
would be left eye Lopes if he was you
know if he was a member of TLC he would
be the complement to left eye Lopes
right right eye naka that's awesome wait
isn't Burke takes d8 followed by is that
queen trapped on a 5 so Brooke takes d8
takes before I get some Queen 86 only
move how do i trap your queen wait night
c7 okay 83 pawn is hanging oh that Queen
is barely surviving so in the night rook
d1 just now c5 okay or not I thought c5
is a bish money to a into Queen 86 this
also looks good
oh she's trapping the Queen cheeky
Hikaru can't sell tonight c7 that's why
she won't Bishop f3
that's unbelievable genius is it we
could get a win No yeahi sevens hanging
so you kick over Kia cos make c7 this is
finally this is are we in the the realm
of not even worried if Danny's gonna
jinx it
yeah are we no sorry I mean don't ya I
don't join jig Dan so Queen have two
good move forcing the Queen exchange
else you want to lose that Bishop on h3
Queen d4 check no that's such a bad
decision because black has so many pawns
here like this is not that easy to win
with all the pawns for black because in
White's time travel eventually black
will play f5 84 submission before it own
at 5:57 check that was kind of neat
so here comes the car responds and 985
good move Kimmy five nicéphore check so
keeping the king away ninety-four now
III checked big blunder oh no no there's
the bishop hanging - uh-huh
I thought we were in the realm of no
return this is yeah we definitely need
some ghee fond love everybody send
positive vibes we will get a victory we
will get a victory
this is yeah that was her game but you
you jinx it Danny why didn't you get
this no you asked if this is a jinx
Danny jinx moment and I said probably
but I didn't want to answer
so okay take on e5 wait isn't night yeah
that's a pond blame Danny blame Canada
Queen f7 just go go bring your queen to
g6 or they'd it's a Bishop g4 Oh
something about this looks suspicious
yeah I don't like the fact that blacks
King is now open the d5 pawn is weak
yeah castling was too slow
King wasn't in trouble in the center so
I thought we move like it was trying to
make progress in the Kings side was the
way to go there
it hurts so fast he's um I think he's
trying to finish with higher than a
minute he will I'm just absolutely
putting on a show here yeah I'm very
impressed honestly I think I think it's
a little fair to say there's a little
bit of tilt going even even as strong as
Hikaru is in Bullitt and as much as
Yvonne is an underdog it's I think I
think let's be fair to say she's pretty
frustrated I'm sure she'll admit admit
as much after the match but she she had
chances to win games in this match and
I'm not saying she still won't get one
but um but right now if you had to ask
well hakarl reach 30 wins or will she
win a game I don't know I don't know
which one I would take what how many
points the car ever now got 21 1/2 he's
got 20 minutes left on the total match
o'clock at 21 and a half points to win 8
games yeah I think he's getting the 30
really ah no I mean I don't know it's
gonna be a tough call we'll see how this
game goes you know a few more games
under my belt to see how quickly he can
win them and yeah I'm just reading the
chat which is always a bad idea but
doing it anyway you know it's sometimes
it's a good idea but people just don't
understand certain things and it's
frustrating to deal with some of the
comments there but I will say as I look
at you know as they'll get back to the
actual chest in a second Yvonne is
someone who is phenomenal chess player
and losing hey Cara Nakamura by the
score is something that can happen to
even the top 10 players in the world in
maxy maxy I'm only score like 10 points
against the color I want to say and
these
right that's true in any
you
right what an ass just want to point out
that you know you find is about to go on
a road scholarship she's not cheating
she's been studying she's been getting
degrees and so her entire focus isn't on
chess but specifically about this time
control as you can tell by her rating
she doesn't play on choice calm so it
just yeah it's a bit frustrating for me
to continue to see comments that should
not even be part of this but anyway back
to this chess game sigh I just realized
everything I just said about Yvonne
wasn't heard by the fans only by you
well yeah I did make some good points
there I should repeat it yep because
what I was trying to highlight for
everyone is that when players of this
level are art when things are going well
and badly for players of this level
sometimes the results are exponentially
bigger than the then the actual skill
gap is in the the the comparison I made
which Robert agreed with that's why he
was that's why you only heard his side
of it is that you know you'll even see
the best-of-seven series in the NBA
where teams will take turn beating each
other by +25 points right just because a
team loses by 30 points doesn't mean
they won't win the next night but when
players it like the the highest level in
the world are playing well do you really
believe that Caruana is 15 games worse
than Aronian I don't I think he I think
he was frustrated he was on tilt as he
said right and I think that you know
LaVon was playing exceptionally well I
think anybody who's been following this
match from the start knows that Yvonne
has had several games where she had both
winning and drawing chances that she was
just unable to convert on so that was my
point is that when players of this level
are are playing really well versus
another one he's playing really badly
the gap can seem wider than it actually
is and you would agree with that yeah
and that's what I was saying that only
you heard that's how I know you agreed
so sorry about that everybody
oh and in this game I mean the card now
just well he's dominating this one as
well because the problem is backwards
upon the e6 and all the queenside pawns
are falling off the board
and just look how quick a car is playing
quickly I should say he's Oh 55 seconds
after at 33 moves he's just playing
instantly every single move and it's
honestly I'm just impressed always when
I watch a car play bullet I'm impressed
when I play against him I'm just
devastated because he makes me feel
terrible yep
because he just moved so quickly and
wins every single game but uh yeah hey
Hikaru just he's got the force when it
comes to bullet chest so Queen takes a
fours know my rook da check that is a
nice tactic that a car was set up so
Queen b6 played in retreat now go back
to d4 and you're trying to hope for an
end game where you have some chances to
the rook take say for now I would play
okay so different move order but I would
have taken on a Ford giving up the e6
pawn and try to trade Queens after that
take on a four you stick with the Queen
yeah it feels like rook takes was
stronger but okay Oh she'll get the
Queen's off and no she will be able to
well here's another time she really
knows so I will not say she will be able
to draw but it is a draw yes
theoretically it's draw practically with
no time on your clock gonna be very
difficult here so let's see
okay she's doing really well here she's
playing quickly she's you know has the
drawing technique of course it's it's
not actually that hard over the board
and with time on your clock but when you
have eight seconds and every move and
you're worried about flagging then it
becomes much more difficult so h5 doing
the right thing though and for those of
us who we've all seen people win and
lose games like this that they shouldn't
but good advice on the from the chess
perspective is the best way to draw
these work endings is to kind of do
exactly what she's doing basically don't
do anything yeah if you can sit tight
for the most part it's it's very
difficult for to make progress without a
blunder and so if you sit tight and
don't blunder you should be able to draw
yep and actually especially with no time
on your clock if you make a move an h5
and then white goes g5 now you have more
being nervous about so I think you're
right and ottoman people the people who
lose these end games I mean
you know Robert and I say it's an easy
draw but I mean I've had students people
lose these names all the time but almost
always it's because they change
something about the position
unnecessarily there are types of games
we're in order to draw you have to find
an accurate defense but there are a lot
of types of games where if you don't
change anything your opponent doesn't
have a winning plan although as I say
that hikaru is I think she did
eventually allow one potential check
that was too much because now he is
breaking through right HMF pond versus
rook and H&M farmer scissors well Dilla
draws yeah it's very difficult this is a
draw if she just if he if he just checks
her says she should check him and
continue checking but she's gonna she's
always in time yeah if she does yep well
down on time she goes we've said that
before today but it's been quite the
show by Hikaru Nakamura and historically
in the speeches championship matches we
look back on on everything it's it's
certainly impressive to see one of them
were lopsided victories for hakarl
regardless of who he's playing and were
I mean we've what was the biggest margin
of victory we've had I don't know it's a
good question we should ask our and that
wasn't just say regardless of who he's
playing that Yvonne didn't have more
potential but obviously I meant that
this is a very very big mismatch on
paper and Hikaru is showing why it was a
big mismatch yes he is and let's see
with here with the black piece it wait
there's an exchange missing I was like
looking just try to see if there any
information with the the largest
differential and then I looked at the
board and blacks up in exchange so yeah
this is this is rough so 95 I don't know
if I would have given up control that
square so it's EEGs b5 no then pawn
takes b5 Oh
so CB what if I take on b5 then take on
f6 and then take on b5 again it wasn't a
pawn
oh the Brooklyn c1 is misplaced oh so
that was a good dozen nice was a nice
tactic that's why I said oh when I saw
it and then I went oh I went oh and then
uh oh god I'm gonna be five is still a
monster man I mean I don't know that
that white doesn't have a certain amount
of compensation here the cars so fast
with the tactics yeah it's ridiculous
like he saw Bishop g5 instantly before
she even made the move so I'm very
impressed
so a minute on the clock again it's it's
just like amazing when you see somebody
who's this good at bullet weight Knight
takes e5 wasn't acting there Jonas that
Knight takes e5 everybody if the rook
took there was Queen f6 check so go back
to d3 and hope that he misses it again
and then brooke takes day for queen
tation for doesn't work anymore
Ali go Knight d3 and pray okay I think I
think she partly saw that she missed
Knight takes e5 too
I had yeah
this is uh this is tough
very very tough here so let's see what's
going on in this game so we see the set
up multiple times with the pawn going to
e4 firmly protected wait now Bishop e7
yep stay with the King and goes of
threat so because 65 yeah which means
you know she's 498 998 there was
probably superior it's also just amazing
to appreciate how obviously we know
because of how fast he is but how many
of these types of positions Robert that
hick ro has probably had before right
he's had so many of these tricks and
some of these positions before cuz he's
played so many online blitz and bullet
games that it's you know partly the
reason why he's able to find them so
fast you know
no that was this game is very impressed
me indicative of exactly what you said
you know indicative not just of talent
but of experience because it car play is
really offbeat opening which he find
clear didn't know she made a blunder and
he's just moving instant he's got minute
and four seconds on the clock and well
this is just demolition time so now
Knight g5 check ft she fired brick brick
f6 check was a tactic that would have
been really really sweet cuz the night
was pinned
double pin double rainbow what happen
now blacks position doesn't look as bad
as well yeah she doesn't have a lot of
time but that's one of those cases where
hikaru if he had spent a few seconds
might have found that roof but okay he's
still up he's still up over a minute
hard to be critical if a car right now
but but it's amazing amazing that he's
still above a minute
you know so tink check push push him
baby
and then d5s hanging with check and he
has already pre moved he said 106 right
now Knight f6 101 in exchange for the g8
square with check hey when you're trying
to pre move to keep yourself a book
blender I know it's gonna say he's
getting himself in trouble with his with
his challenge of himself to stay above a
minute I just know that that's what he's
thinking that that's rook a 5 Claybrook
a 5 no she could have played it now
she's never playing rugger 5 obviously
yep now he's oh he's gonna bring the
knight around to f5 at some point well
they might take on e7 I guess so ok yeah
so King g6 draw I think this would best
play this should be a draw but with the
clock situation as it currently is I
don't think a car was gonna take the
draw he'll no way so I'll play he'll do
something Kenya's cut off that's a real
problem is there's no way to actually
yeah maybe would you like do something
but he can't really cuz his own king ah
he found a trick a for trick over kept
six okay our king of sleaze wait he lost
a pipe on yep now it's over
well she put the King on h6 which was a
mistake because that put put her in
territory everyone where he could
actually fork on f5 and win the rook on
e7 so but under time pressure sometimes
you forget things like that and six
minutes left for him to reach 30 games
yep
I really just want just to a come to a
conclusion that just it's hurting it's
hurting for sure
so let's see Queen f6 okay so age for I
mean she's not playing aggressively
she's playing well but time is never her
friend that's the real issue
so mission g7 takes okay
h5 okay for that's a funny square a king
b1 just protect yeah if you take on h4
with your rook oppai rook F 1 so
Nakamura protects the F file but he Fon
just keeps going after now quit h4 isn't
about Queen c3 checks as our Queen e5
was played and Queen up to you couldn't
go over a fake as a7 was hanging so you
find him very well on both sides of the
board here in fact playing brilliantly
and some Queen takes tea sounds a free
pawn so this is one of those games where
you know we're like we see we've been
here before we've seen her get a great
position what seems like an
insurmountable lead in terms of the
evaluation but clock situation happens
and all goes wrong so there she has a
lot of time though I mean you'd I was
wonder if she should have just gone for
Queen h8 there but okay the Queen h8 is
calling my name
why not you know Queen each eight was
very good there
he's setting up a perpetual Oh
the more she opens her King so queen
eh-eh just bring your queen in queen
eh-eh has been winning first sometime oh
really
no I just not anymore but I mean Phenom
it was winning the h7 phone with check
for quite some time so got it okay now
she has he is
she is queen she ate bishops and she's
six
so Queen g5 check there it is yeah she's
got a lot of time left
yeah this is okay Queen chime check
should still be okay just trying to make
it draw fish about five they should play
Bishop a5 Bishop a5 wins or yeah okay
there we go
she goes for it now Queen DHX a threat
so you have to do something about this
auto-ship missing h6 wait so what do you
do now Queen geez yep she played it b6
hangs to check if you go 58 he's going
for it though it come b6 just takes me
six with check no no I was winning she
did everything correct ever it was
winning now she'll have to settle on a
draw if a car takes on d7 and tries the
flagger that would be so nasty that
would be something yeah but so it's it's
crazy because in a feed a game or
something you still get points for
beating so on tremendously lower than
you but I think our beef on just got a
whole bunch of points for that the karo
gets - -8 points for his effort today
yeah that's pretty funny
yeah so okay she got she got the half
point she'd have won that game should've
won that game but we've been there
before right well yeah this is an
evaluation and I think like I said which
is why I feel that it's not unfair to
say that part of the results here is
also just uh what happens when you start
losing a match like this these these
players don't get to take a rest day and
they don't even get to take really 10-15
minutes to refresh themselves you know
they're only a 10-15 seconds as soon as
the game's over it's you know these
things are really trials of you know an
epic online blitz or bullet session you
know that these you know these players
have played but this is like if you were
losing this badly and not on camera
required to keep playing what would you
do you would probably just stop and go
get a drink maybe throw your computer
out the window and call it a day you
know I mean like the fact that you have
to keep playing right now and you're
down 20 games it's just not fun so I
like blacks position here yeah I mean I
just it's rough I like blacks position
time situation okay for now the one
second increment you know it is a lot of
for those who are experienced with
bullet yeah I play quite quite deal
bullet on chess i comp server yeah one
second increments actually pretty huge
but the problem is if you're not super
experienced pre moving I went to pre
move and things like that it becomes
very difficult no matter what increment
is on the board so yep yeah I agree with
collector collector Rama collector rumah
just said that you know yeah she's lost
a lot of games but she's had a lot of
good positions and clearly in terms of
the chess rank she deserves to be in
this event and we'll be back and I don't
I don't expect her to if he well I don't
expect a lot of people to beat Hikaru
anyway in this format but you know I
think um I think she just needs to work
on her time management yep
so let's see King age four year four
Hakkar that's super it frustrating to
see that King on h4 because you had
LightSquared Bishop which means you can
never give it a check and so the king is
in a beautiful position
here just it's gonna stay there for the
rest of the game you came here up from
well you can we work from ehh because if
I take on H 5 then I might get myself
mated so now King up 6
ok ok have sex with d6 pawn hangs so is
if I'm just gonna go back and forth like
8 now what do you laughing about it is
laughing at some of the twitch comets oh
yeah
so now h5 is going down yeah f5 wait a
creative way to work through I like it
that was really nice yeah check check
again push the seat bone yep bye Brooke
g5 chequered wait what what's going on
here that felt like the wrong decision
by Takara car I agree I mean now his
king is actually trapped in a way that
changes the way you look at the young
okay not anymore
I guess I gave 7 oh it's not me it was a
way isn't rookie to mate but the king
obviously came out wait so then rooks
just check forever now it looks like it
yeah not worth playing this one on for a
win so draw a draw again and Hikaru is
officially below 3,100 let's just say he
lost the match he's losing rating points
wait did they start this before the time
went out sorry what did they start this
game I guess I started just before the
clock pretty sure it counts although I
admit I wasn't following closely enough
to say but okay I think I think we let
them play before the interview portion
begins
ah time was up for about 30 seconds but
they rematched and we didn't notice well
let's see what's going on here so he
fine with the white pieces again more
space and when he car is done really
well Danny yeah gotta give him credit
he's out such a good job of getting
positions without symmetry and he's been
retaining the Knights and giving his eye
he found the bishop so he's in a really
good job of doing that to make sure that
he can control the squares that the
bishop was not on and in a position like
well I don't know but I have five demo
that's quite bad actually isn't logistic
but I think you're right also just from
a practical point of view that it
creates an oh she just went upon here
but creates an imbalance that allows her
to outplay allows him to outplay her and
I think it's in some ways it's harder to
deal with a knight and bullet against
the night because you're you're you're
always in danger of being tricked and so
I agree with you I think that the
practical decision that he's had to have
a lot of night versus Bishop positions
has helped yep oh okay there's gotta be
a mate looming one of those positions
where you see that fish went up to rook
on da combination so Percy for pawn of
rook t1 along with that yeah rook do you
want for a little bit too defensive yeah
rather than something like Queen of
three well the rook was on the eighth
rank so none not sure she is still up a
pawn no yes she is
yes but I would play b4 here I don't
know if it works but I'm you know and
before it's right over the Year Dan
handled anything back now exactly if
Queen e8 here b4 just I'm not sure the
players know it's the last game but I
believe we have notified them so and if
they start another one we will
definitely abort it according to our
official match game clock which is a
couple seconds off the show I guess
somebody said that they felt that they
got the game in but either way Bob's
your uncle
games being played and it counts yep
Danny can you turn it to coach Klein
should I call you red Beaulieu you are I
mean you make a waterboy reference and I
just gotta you got to bring it
I got a continuing right I have a choice
but okay so Queen D so light squares
Queens and nights before guess I know
I'm just living together it was a little
bit too late though
wait see for falling Bueller no I've
taken c4 I play go BC finding Brooke see
one and then c5 would hop fall all the
time the night was overwhelm there okay
that's a losing end game yep H pawn is
strong man yep and winning the chief
pawn as well and with it the game the
match the set is over and we will
actually bring both players on on with
us here yes here if they are they are
they're here longer I'm here you phone
can you hear mom can you hear me oh yeah
do you - it seems like there's a am I
the only one getting it now I hear that
go to Howard oh that's better okay well
um
he fought I obviously obviously was it
was a tough match but it felt that there
were a lot of games a lot of a lot of
good positions you had and a lot of
games where without without some time
pressure the result could have been
different
whether it was games that could have
been drawn or or wins and what was your
perspective on that did you just feel
that being down on time was it was a big
part of the problem and at least from
our perspective it seems like that the
quality of chess was really good just
down on time in a lot of games
like most of the five and also three
which I'm quite disappointed like I miss
so many good sensations but actually
definitely must be improved quite a lot
in case you really want to improve the
resorts right the hick horrible but what
were your thoughts on that how did you
feel you played today obviously a great
match victory and congratulations moving
on and but what were your thoughts on
the on the chest and how how some of
those games broke down in time scrambles
yeah I mean I think and the five minute
really the start of the match was
crucial once we fund not get she didn't
shoot any of those first couple of games
once I got the big advantage at all like
it really was never in danger I mean
that being said at some point when
you're up like so many games it becomes
a little bit difficult to to stay
focused and I mean I felt like in the
treatment already it was starting to
drift a little bit and then the bowl
certainly it was just same thing but
yeah I mean I think in the five minute
at least we found got some great
positions but I defended quite well and
she wasn't able to convert in the onion
her car you tend to be pretty you know
emotive at least facially there was one
game where you won but white if I could
have like C 8 equals Queen and you were
shaking your head for like the first I
don't know 20 seconds of the game after
that did you just like did you see that
afterwards and yeah your head not uh
seems to give it away here yeah I mean I
think what happened is well first hold
on I'm thinking back I think I could
have played rook G 2 and G 5 no I think
I said virtuous remark yes but but yeah
I think the thing is that I just I
thought it was just meeting I calculate
a few memos before when I played out
five and then I don't think red shirt
right away then as soon as the game's
her it's like it's only hit me it's like
wait a second see it defense h3 and and
so yeah I realize that
obviously that fact that if I would if
we find him play C 20 equals Queen on it
would have been a very it would have
been a lot of clothes or anything but
yeah I mean sometimes those sorts of
oversights happen
if you're forced enough to not to not
not lose when you make the sort of
errors it's generally gonna go your way
you phone I know you don't play online
Blitzen bullet as much as as much as
Hikaru or some others but is it is that
something that you feel have a hard time
managing time pressure under under when
you're in a tiny screaming board do you
feel like it was just the Takara was so
fast that you know because he's really
good too so what were your thoughts on
that is this something that makes you
want to play more online Blitzen bullet
yeah I think awesome especially stopping
the bullet Chas where I fell like up you
know like the president's Orion actually
doesn't know that sometimes
actually it's my turn to move so I
thought that probably more get used to
that
I mean basically it's just like um let's
say a person tries it because we already
spent too much time with the computer
their part on really I mean very keen to
play online but probably I should do
that more often later on you'll have a
lot of time coming up while at Oxford
right I'm sure you'll have plenty of
time for chess online obviously kidding
but when did you know that you you
missed the chance that the game that
Robert just has a car about to Queen on
c8 and and actually you were winning in
the final position when you resigned or
did you did you were you just kind of
frustrated at that point and didn't
didn't see that okay well Hikaru we we
talked a little bit about the the next
matchup that you'll be having here you
will be facing the winner of Maxime
vache The Grove and lay near Dominguez
Perez you said you feel that author I
think it was before the show started you
told me in Robert you felt that MDL was
probably the favorite but the Dominguez
you think could could upset him in that
match who would you rather play um I
mean it doesn't really matter to me I
mean I think actually I'm gonna pick
Tameka as to win that match on it you
forced me to take someone I'm gonna pick
T Mingus when that but I expect to be
very close and I played both of them
many times I think I kind of would
prefer to play to mean Gus simply
because I think I played Maxine every
every speed championship
ham chip so far and obviously played a
lot in the Grantchester so it'd be nice
to have a little variety but I wouldn't
be shocked if Maxine went so it should
be interesting
got it well iPhone and Nagara it was a
great match as far as the fans and the
the chess entertainment instruction was
concerned so we we appreciate that
Robert you have any final questions
before we let our players go no it's
pretty late here in New York so I think
I'm out of questions for this one okay
really fun it's not late there your days
just getting going so have a great one a
little bit a little bit better match
start time than your first year against
Caruana but we hope to have you back
next year again and and maybe with a
little bit more experience in the format
a better result maybe thank you so much
hey Carlo congratulations and we will
see you in the next matchup and cheers
thanks to all the fans everyone who
tuned in everyone who donated for the
prize fund for the players and all of
our subscribers all of our members we
appreciate you we love you
we're out I think we're gonna send a
host here so if you're in the mood for
some chef's don't go anywhere and watch
the next person up and Robert I will see
you on Sunday with wayy taking on Wesley
cell
you